[Musique]
Laurenttoon, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? 40 ans
cette année. Euh journaliste repenti,
écrivain depuis 2013 avec la France
Orange mécanique Guerria et aujourd'hui
guerre. Voilà le petit dernier. On
vous avait reçu il y a 6 ans. Hm
hm.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé depuis ?
Je suis passé de l'extrême droite à
l'ultradroite dans les qualificatifs des
de mes ex-confrères et enfin moi j'ai
continué à faire mon chemin. Pour moi,
ça ça voilà pas une évolution
significative. J'ai continué à essayer
de semer, porter la mauvaise parole euh
et à essayer de d'éveiller quelques
esprits, réarmer les pensées comme je
l'explique dans mes bouquins. Je suis
plus plutôt passé sur le au début
j'étais plutôt sur le constat et
maintenant sur le versant solution,
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et cetera.
Donc par extension, développement
personnel en quelque sorte
et matrimoniale, pourquoi pas ?
résout résout les problèmes, les
cancers, les maladies graves et cetera.
Marabou
marabou. Ouais. Ouais. Euh non mais
voilà, il y a une demande qui est très
forte du lectorat et j'essaie de
d'apporter des réponses sans me dérober
le côté je me contente du constat et
c'est tout.
Donc vous avez sorti des bouquins quand
même à succès
avec un certain public. Ça a été vendu à
combien d'exemplaires ? La France Orange
Mécanique et tous les autres. Alors là,
il faudrait compiler toutes les
rééditions, les formats différents.
Range mécanique, je crois qu'on était à
300000 et quelques. Les guerriillas, ça
doit être à peu près pareil. Les autres
un peu moins, mais quand même ça reste
tout à fait correct. Le la trilogie et
loge de la force game over et guerre
fonctionne aussi très bien. Donc là,
c'est vraiment l'aspect l'aspect
solution. Quoi quoi que je fasse, les
lecteurs m'ont suivi donc un peu moins
sur les récits criminels, Utoya, Diab du
Ciel, voilà, mais par contre sur les les
les essais de société là là ça marche.
Ouais,
c'était des essais un peu
prospectivistes, non ? C'est que on a
même entendu dans la bouche de certains
politiques la France orange mécanique.
Alors comme
Ah oui, c'est devenu un terme Ouais.
mainstream en quelque sorte la notion
d'ensauvagement
qui allait avec. Oui, c'est ça a
complètement passé dans le langage
courant. C'était en 2013 et ça c'était
pour le coup vraiment le constat du
jour. Les certains lecteurs me disaient
"Mais vous êtes un visionnaire, jeis pas
du tout." Enfin, on a ça sous les yeux
depuis des années. Euh, il suffit de il
suffit de les ouvrir les yeux et de
décrire ce qui se passe. Là, après
Guerria, c'était plus l'anticipation.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer dans les
années qui arrivent ? Qu'est-ce qu'on
peut comment peut évoluer une situation
aussi merdique qui est la nôtre avec les
difficultés économiques, sociales,
l'immigration, l'insécurité ? Donc
j'imaginais le l'étincelle, le grand
effondrement et guerre et loge de la
force, c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait nous ?
Voilà
la chose, monsieur Moyen aux éditions
Magnus, donc
Robert
Robert et Robert plus pas que Robert
parce que
Roberte, c'est ça
Robert éventuellement. taper
taper
au début je partais sur vraiment Robert
monsieur moyen, bavulèvre JT de TF1
celui qui qui voit mais qui n'entend
pas. Et après mes lecteurs m'ont dit
"Oui mais nous c'est trop facile, on est
averti, tu nous prends pour des abrutis,
nous on sait tout ça comme toi et on
veut que tu nous tu nous parles comme à
des adultes. On veut des des solutions
des vraies pistes. Et bon
il y a pas de solution mis à part Tib,
on va dire pas mis à part youtubeur,
préparateur physique, agence
matrimoniale.
Bah c'est déjà pas mal. Si euh si Robert
trouve Robert, honnêtement, je serais
déjà assez content.
On va en reparler. Alors, avant de
commencer tout ça, on va prendre notre
temps.
Pourquoi on vous qualifie
de gars d'ultradroite ? Quelles sont les
grifs qui vous sont reprochées ? C'est
vos amis ? C'est votre maison d'édition
? C'est là où vous étiez ? Pourquoi on
vous reproche ça ?
Le qualificatif, le problème c'est qui
donne l'étiquette au départ. Et moi,
j'aimerais bien rencontrer le gars qui a
décidé un jour lui il est d'ultra droite
ou d'extrême droite au début. après
ultra droite parce que extrême droite il
y en avait trop, ça n'allait plus et
maintenant je suis pas giga droite,
enfin je fais plus trop attention mais
si on part du principe que Alain Jup
droite c'est sûr ouais oui giga droite
pas de problème enfin je signne mais euh
quand on interroge ceux qui donnent ces
étiquettes, on constate qu'ils ont
beaucoup de mal à définir à donner des
des critères objectifs de ça de dire
"Oui mais pourquoi concrètement enfin
économiquement par rapport à qui ? sur
parce que je dis que l'immigration de
quantité euh pose des problèmes parce
que je dis que la justice est laxiste
enfin j'en sais rien quels sont
si je vous dis d'ailleurs je reprends ce
qui est dans votre bouquin on lira
quelques passages.
Il faut qu'il y a un partenaire pour
pour boxer. C'est ça. On explique ça
dans votre bouquin et plus le partenaire
est puissant mieux c'est pour vous.
Ouais évidemment. Bah oui
on se boxe alors.
Alors pourquoi on vous qualifie
d'extrême droite ? Quand j'ai lu votre
bouquin, vous armez certes les esprits
avec votre prisme de lecture, mais vous
appelez à l'armement physique avec des
ballle, avec du tir, avec de
l'endurcissement physique à la limite
d'une préparation militaire plus avec un
champ sémantique dur. C'est peut-être
pour ça que vos détracteurs vous
qualifient dans la mouvance ultra
droite. Ces sessionnistes
qui sont en train de s'armer,
s'organiser
en mode milicien. Est-ce que vous pouvez
comprendre aussi ça que ça peut faire
peur ? Ah oui, je comprends que ça fasse
peur mais moi enfin ça me ferait plus
peur qu'on continue euh comme Robert à
être un une sorte de cochon domestique
et qui attend qui attend son heure. Euh
je pense que il faut justement se
préparer à des temps difficiles. On a
malheureusement connu depuis qu'on est
né, depuis une génération ou deux
situation de confort sans précédent
historique et on n jamais été confronté
à
de la paix.
Oui. Oui. Voilà. On n'a jamais été
confronté à ça et le confort bah
dégénère fait que on s'habitue à ça et
qu'on cherche par tous les moyens à
éviter la confrontation et les preuve et
le problème c'est que ça viendra. C'est
on
on va venir sur la prospective un peu
plus tard. Moi je vais vous lire un
passage
qui peut être interprété comme dangereux
d'extrême droite et tout ce qui va avec.
D'accord. Page 233 du livre Laurent
Roberto Guer. Il ne suffit pas de
critiquer ou de réfuter les délires de
la secte. On va reparler aussi de de
cette histoire de secte. Il faut les
faire sauter une sape creusée sauf
fondation une charge énorme de de TNT et
booum.
Oui, vous êtes relu quand vous avez
écrit ça. C'est
une belle image. Oui, je me relis
toujours. Je m'étonne toujours
d'ailleurs de ce que j'écris parce que
on est on n'est pas on n'est pas
exactement ce qu'on écrit. Notre moi
sociale est un peu différent de ça.
Bref, je suis pas ce que je parle non
plus. C'est comme ça, on est un peu
victime de soi. Et oui, oui, je
comprends, je conçois que les images
martiales, mobilisatrices
puissent paraître un peu un peu raide.
Mais encore une fois, moi je j'ai je
pense que c c'est la situation, cette
secte qui nous qui essaie de présider à
nos pensées, qui essaie de nous de nous
comment dire de détenir nos âmes, elle
est dangereuse, elle nous met en danger
et par conséquent il faut qu'on trouve
les moyens d' de lui opposer quelque
chose. Je vais pisser.
Bien joué, bien vu. Désolé d'avoir
coupé.
Est-ce que ça vous comprenez que ça peut
faire excessivement peur et générer des
adhérences en face qui en fait créent
des démons comme par exemple Ultra
gauche qui crée ses propres démons dans
l'ultra droite à force de les
ostraciser, de les pister, de les
chambrer, de faire des attaques
journalistiques coordonnées en
s'appelant à gauche à droite. Est-ce que
vous comprenez que vous de votre côté,
comme l'autre côté de la pièce, vous
vous autoalimentez
ce côté euh excusez-moi, je vais essayer
d'utiliser un vocabulaire pointe de
diamant comme vous le décrivez dans
votre livre.
Ça génère en fait des démons des deux
côtés. Est-ce que il n'est pas temps si
vous anticipez euh un effondrement, un
état renégat, des services publics qui
calanchent, un état économique
dramatique, est-ce qu'il est peut-être
encore temps de trouver un consensus
pour se réconcilier ? Alors se
réconcilie, je sais pas jusqu'où peut
aller la réconciliation, mais je pense
oui que mes bouquins servent à sont des
ce sont des des bombes mentales en
quelque sorte, mais pour euh que la
réaction ait lieu avant que
l'effondrement soit là, quand j'écris
guerriage, j'ai envie évidemment de
susciter une réaction pour qu'on se dise
où est-on en train d'aller ? Il faut
faire quelque chose maintenant, sinon ce
sera beaucoup plus couteau, beaucoup
plus dur plus tard si on attend. Et
enfin, moi j'ai l'impression, j'ai la
faiblesse de penser que je suis lu par
des gens adultes et responsables et qui
n'en tireront pas des des de mauvaises
conclusions qui se comport qui se
comporteront correctement. Euh bon après
voilà, le problème c'est que il y a des
types qui ont massacré des gens après
avoir écouté des chansons des Beatles.
Enfin, on peut pas maîtriser les
répercussions euh intellectuelles que
vont générer des lectures chez chez chez
tout un chacun. Chacun, il y a un
bouquin par lecteur. Je suis étonné des
fois de l'interprétation qui est faite,
de ce que j'écris. Moi, j'ai
l'impression de de de d'être clair. Je
je dis assez clairement qu'il faut pas
faire de bêtises, que pour moi, les
citoyens honnêtes qui n'ont pas fait
défaut ont le droit de s'arer s'ils
veulent. Pourquoi pas ? Pourquoi
j'aurais pas le droit de me balader avec
mon avec mon pistolet sur moi si je m'en
sers pas pour tirer sur sur les vélos
taffeurs ?
C'est interdit. Oui, j'ai le droit d' on
a le droit d'en détenir chez soi, mais
on n pas le droit de sans motif.
Euh comme aller chez l'armurier au
centre de tir, on n pas le droit de se
balader dans la rue avec une arme.
Vous avez une fatoua derrière vous que
vous
si on a le petit mot de retaillot qui
nous y autorise mais c'est rare et bon
c'est un peu un peu contraignant.
On va recevoir dans pas très longtemps
un avocat qui s'est fait beaucoup
emmerder et qui potentiellement a un
port d'armes ou de garde du corps
d'ailleurs. Revenons à votre bouquin.
Euh vous parlez de dressage.
H
quelle est la différence entre dressage
et éducation ?
Alors le c'est une différence de de mots
parce que il y a pas vraiment de de de
différence sur le papier. Aujourd'hui,
le dressage est pratiqué exactement de
la enfin de la même manière qu'une
éducation. Euh
ça c'est caca. Euh l'extrême droite,
voilà. et gauche ou oui, ça dépend
comment de quel côté on se place ou euh
ça c'est bien, c'est une bon discours,
félicitation susucre, tu auras ta
récompense. On fait je sais pas, on nous
fait réciter des discours. Par exemple,
la diversité est une richesse, le vivre
ensemble est fantastique. Vous envoyez
le chien, vous le dressez pour aller
chercher le journal, c'est pareil.
Socialement, on va vous flatter, vous
allez marquer des points, c'est très
bien pour vous. Par contre, si vous
tenez un discours déviant euh considéré
comme hérétique, ce sera l'inverse. La
menace de de d'exclusion,
d'excommunication, de euh d'abandon. Et
chez l'animal domestique, c'est une peur
euh qui est qui est profonde parce que
elle est vitale. Un chien qui est
abandonné, il meurt la plupart du temps.
Et on a cette même impression. Si notre
groupe,
si vous avez un perger du coaucase, vous
êtes tranquille.
Oui, ça dépend des des espèces. Mais
normalement les animaux domestiques, la
caractéristique c'est qu'ils ont besoin
du maître pour vivre et sans lui c'est
pas possible et nous c'est le groupe. Et
voilà, on c'est pour ça qu'on est si
conformiste. On adopte des jugements qui
qu'on estime à peu près acceptable et
c'est donc ça fonctionne pareil. la
télévision, le conditionnement de la
télévision ou la manière dont la plupart
des gens élèvent leurs enfants et repose
sur les mêmes bases.
Vous parlez d'une secte.
Oui.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire dans votre
livre le mot secte ? Ben, c'est une
vaste entreprise de dénis des réalités.
Euh une idéologie qui a qui a qui a pris
à peu près tous les pouvoirs qu'il était
possible de prendre. euh l'État, les
médias, le les la magistrature,
l'université, enfin tout ce qui peut
avoir accès justement à ces leviers de
conditionnement, tout ce qui peut
accéder à la représentation publique.
Vous appelez ça une secte de gauchiste.
Oui, parce que son tropisme, enfin c'est
elle va le monstre nage toujours vers la
gauche comme disait l'autre. Euh il y a
je crois que c'est je veux pas dire de
conneries soit Nick Lang ou Kurty
Serviervin plutôt Curty Siervin
a beaucoup écrit là-dessus sur cette
logique la la secte elle veut le pouvoir
elle veut l'emprise sur les âmes donc
elle va promettre des changements
permanents
dans la dans sur la nature humaine. elle
va elle va promettre des des actes, une
administration parce que il y a
inégalité, c'est scandaleux, donc il
faut correction, donc il faut tout un
appareil euh pour pour contrôler ça, des
experts, des régulations, des lois, des
machins. Donc à partir de là, forcément
sa nature est plutôt de gauche. Elle est
étatiste, elle est interventionniste,
elle est égalitaire. Euh et ça ça laisse
de moins en moins de champ aux libertés
individuelles. Et
tous les la secte sont enfin sa
caractéristique c'est qu'elle n'a pas
vraiment de de chef. Elle a pas de il y
a personne en haut qui qui qui écrit la
notice. À mon avis, il y a une collusion
d'intérêt assez fantastique qui se
partage le pouvoir qu'elle peut
procurer. Ça va du du type de tout en
bas de la lycéenne à cheveux à cheveux
bleus qui vous fait des leçons de morale
à Manuel Vals en passant par tous les
autres. Et tout le monde peut participer
si moi demain j'ai envie de je sais pas
d'adopter n'importe quel discours à la
mode.
C'est quoi un discours à la mode ? Je
sais pas les enfants non n'ont pas il y
a pas de il y a pas d'homme, il y a pas
de femme, on peut faire ce qu'on veut,
c'est une question de de choix
personnel. Par exemple, c'est à la mode
et si je veux être progressiste, si je
veux être à la mode, je dois adopter ce
ce discours là. Et je peux donc moi à
mon tour avoir ce ce petit plus, cette
supériorité morale par rapport à Robert
qui est qui lui ne se rend pas compte
que qui qu'il est toujours à l'ancien
schéma. Il pensent qu'il y a des hommes,
qu'il y a des femmes et que et voilà et
que le reste est assez anecdotique.
Tenez-moi trois de vos qualités, trois
de vos défauts et ensuite trois qualités
de la secte et trois défauts de la
secte. Ce que vous appelez secte.
Trois qualités me concernant.
Je sais pas, après c'est des qualités
qui sont à mon service.
La ténacité,
capacité de travail peut-être. Euh
je pense une certaine euh un certain
sens des responsabilités. J'ai envie que
mes enfants soient fier de moi, de ce
que je suis, de ma donc je fais
attention à ma réputation et je suis
assez sévère avec moi-même. Je suis un
juge assez euh assez sévère. Je fais pas
de grandes proclamations, de grandes
leçons de conduite que je ne m'applique
pas. J'essaie hein, je suis pas toujours
le mon meilleur élève mais j'essaie en
tout cas de commencer par moi.
Trois défauts.
Trois défauts. Euh je sais pas, je suis
pas assez vicieux parce que dans le dans
le monde médiatique, malheureusement
pour être bon, il faut être vicieux, il
faut mentir beaucoup, séduire,
promettre, ne pas hésiter à tromper,
intriguer.
Intriguer, voilà. Avoir un réseau. Je je
sais pas faire non plus. J'ai c'est
désastreux. J'attends que les gens
viennent à moi un peu par hasard et je
sais pas me placer. Je sais, je sais pas
faire ça. Et euh je sais pas sinon à
part ça non. Je
qu'est-ce que je pourrais dire de plus ?
Euh
je mange pas beaucoup de légumes.
Pourtant dans votre bouquin, vous prenez
défut
une hygiène d'assette comme un sportif
qui se permettrait qu'une seule fois par
mois un repas gras. Vous prêchez
l'abandon des tissus mou par
l'endurcissement corporel.
Ouais,
on en reviendra. Euh trois qualités et
trois défauts de ce que vous considérez
comme une secte.
Bah la qualité c'est que elle a éliminer
tous les contrepouvoirs à peu près, peu
de choses près. La souveraineté
populaire n'est plus du tout un
problème. Euh la noblesse a disparu du
paysage. Le le la religion est
complètement inspirée par le
progressisme triomphant.
Donc
disons qu'elle a elle a elle a réussi.
C'est une secte qui a réussi pour
l'instant. Et là, les moyens de
propagande les plus eff enfin
conséquents en tout cas, peut-être pas
les plus efficaces parce que ces agents
sont pas toujours les meilleurs mais et
là une structure de propagande qui est
inédite sans précédent, une emprise
morale sur les esprits qui est qui est
devenue planétaire et ça encore une fois
qualité ça
bah pour elle encore une fois c'est une
qualité qui qui qui la sert les
justement après elle peut avoir le
défaut euh du fait que c'est un appareil
que il y a des activistes qui vont sont
sûrement beaucoup trop loin pour elle
qui lui font du tort.
Ça va trop vite pour Robert par exemple
qui a du mal à comprendre ce qui se
passe et qui voit par le biais de ses
activistes enragés qu'il y a des
problèmes et ça ça pourrait le faire
remettre en question un petit peu la la
nourriture intellectuelle qu'on essaie
de lui de lui donner. Euh ça pourrait
être ça son défaut. Voilà. Mais sinon
malheureusement non, elle est assez
assez assez efficace. Évidemment, sa
meilleure chance, c'est la passivité
globale de de des sujets domestiques.
Alors, c'est c'est intéressant parce que
vous parlez de domestication, de
dressage et de de choses comme ça.
H
Je repose la question. Quelle est la
différence entre dressage et éducation ?
Alors, si on veut
alors côté animal et côté je sais pas si
on peut appeler le terme dressage pour
les humains,
peut-être conditionnement.
Ouais, si conditionnement, mais enfin
côté animal, quelle est la différence
entre dressage et et éducation ?
L'animal, c'est un chantage un peu
perpétuel. Soit il se comporte bien, il
est récompensé. Soit il se comporte mal,
il est puni. Quand on y réfléchit,
l'éducation repose énormément sur le
chantage. Euh mange ta soupe sinon. Fais
pas ça sinon. Ou alors fais ça, c'est
bien.
Vous parlez beaucoup de chiens. Vous
parlez beaucoup de chiens de
domestication et de choses comme ça.
Vous avez déjà eu un chien ?
Le Non, pas les chiens. Non.
Vous avez eu quoi ? des chats.
Oh, ça s'éduque pas les chats.
Non, justement, j'aime bien ce côté euh
ce côté indomestique. Le le chat n'est
pas vraiment un animal domestique.
Ouais.
Et et côté chien, comment on fait pour
se faire obéir ou se faire respecter ?
Il faut se positionner en leader, il
faut se positionner en tant que celui
qui aide à mieux vivre. Comment ça se ça
fonctionne ? Bah le enfin comme les
animaux domestiques, ils ont une une
imagerie mentale. Ils sont programmés
pour avoir cette figure du maître et
nous aussi hein. Malheureusement.
Vous avez lu quoi concernant ce sujetl
? Oh essentiellement les étologues qu'on
rad Lawrence, on avait déjà parlé la
dernière fois qui a d'ailleurs écrit un
bouquin sur les chiens et les chats
qui aussi un peu mal tourné qui était un
peu nazi non ? Oh, il a été accusé mais
à cette époque-là euh comme un peu tout
le monde, comme tous les savants qui qui
qui n'ont pas eu le temps de faire leur
faire leur valises. Mais euh non, enfin,
a priori, il était assez distant avec
euh avec tout ça. Euh et par contre, ses
travaux sur la domestication sont
vraiment de tout premier ordre. Et il
est le premier.
C'est quoi c'est quoi un réflexe de
Lawrence ?
La question m'a déjà été posée la
dernière fois. Alors, ça m'a intrigué.
Je me suis dit mais le réflexe de Pavlov
ou je dis pas mais le réflexe de
Lawrence j'ai cherché et j'ai toujours
pas trouvé
dans ces dans les bouquins que j'ai de
lui. En tout cas, j'ai pas trouvé ça.
Bah regardez quand un animal en face de
vous euh déglit.
Ouais.
C'est c'est pour un un geste
d'apaisement.
D'accord.
Faire sa toilette chez l'homme nettoy
les rituels d'apaisement. OK. Ben moi
j'avais cette notion le rituel. Oui,
quand il y a loi qui arrive et qui tout
de suite crée un ryth pour s'apaiser ça,
ouais. OK, ça j'ai
Bon, revenons, revenons à nos moutons.
J'espère avoir réussi à déconcentrer un
peu.
Quand vous parlez de secte, quand vous
parlez dans votre bouquin de côté
chevalesque, de grandeur, de posture,
même en marchant, il faut se tenir
droit, la tête haute. Est-ce que c'est
pas vous vous rabaisser
de décrire
quelque chose en face ? comme sectaire,
est-ce que vous aviez peut-être un
manque de maturité ou un manque de
vision à long terme ? C'est un peu comme
les gens d'ultra gauche qui vous
insultent tous les jours. Est-ce que il
faut peut-être arrêter de toujours
s'insulter ?
Bah est-ce que c'est une insulte ?
Enfin, c'est un c'est un constat. C'est
difficile de constater autrement la
chose. Vous lisez la définition de
l'emprise sectaire,
le côté endoctrinement des enfants,
modification du langage, euh exigences
financière exorbitantes, euh enfin en
prise sur les âmes, sur le comportement.
Euh on est en captivité aujourd'hui.
Vous naissez, vous êtes immatriculé,
vous pouvez pas échapper à l'État
français toute votre vie. On dit que
vous êtes consentant à l'impôt, bah vous
consentez pas, c'est pareil, vous les
perrez.
et et vous allez mourir aussi euh dans
le cadre légal bientôt. Ça va être tout
ça va être encadré aussi. Votre
éducation aussi, elle n'appartient elle
appartient de moins en moins à la
volonté des des parents. Euh donc, on
est complètement dépossédé petit à petit
de nos de notre marge de manœuvre si
tentez qu'on en a une au départ. Donc
oui, c'est pour ça que je parle de ça
parce que pour moi le le terme est
vraiment vraiment juste. Il y a une il y
a il y a une il y a un délire
idéologique, délire sectaire et en
général le problème c'est que ça finit
souvent assez mal parce que alors c'est
toujours au nom du bien pour le bien de
tous que ces gens agissent mais le
problème c'est que c'est toujours ça qui
les bonnes intentions, ça se finit
souvent très mal. Ça fait beaucoup de
morts. Après, c'est bien, on a une bonne
conscience, on dort bien la nuit, mais
malheureusement bien plus facile de pas
se remettre en cause, de se dire que euh
bah oui, si on fait ça, c'est pour le
bien de tous. Et moi, j'ai du mal j'ai
du mal à faire ça. J'ai j'ai vraiment du
mal à même moi, me dire que j'agis pour
le bien de tout. J'en sais rien. Je me
contente déjà de moi des miens de leur
donner quelques quelques petits quelques
petits comment dire petits indices
quelques petit
je sais pas des des des aides
des petits messages des trucs que j'ai
lu, des trucs que j'ai je crois avoir à
peu près compris mais c'est tout. Je
suis pas du tout je veux pas être un
contregourou et je l'explique à chaque
fois à mes lecteurs. Vous savez pas qui
je suis, vous savez pas quelle est ma
réalité, vous savez pas ce que je veux
vraiment. Moi, je vends des bouquins, je
suis un je suis aussi un marchand. Euh,
peut-être que c'est tout, que je je veux
juste vendre mes bouquins et voilà,
profiter de ça. J'ai trouvé mon créneau,
je suis content. Donc, faites attention,
méfiez-vous, soyez sceptiques toujours.
Ne ne ne vous précipitez pas dans une
autre erreur.
Est-ce que vous pensez que le camp d'en
face, puisque j'ai l'impression qu'il y
a deux camps de de de côté de la pièce,
peut aussi vous considérer
comme secctaire ? Est-ce qu' vous
comprenez aussi que l'extrême droite
peut être aussi considéré comme
secctaire le fait de prêcher
l'endurcissement corporel, de prêcher
des valeurs alimentaires de
d'endurcissement alimentaires, de se
réveiller le matin avec une douche
glacée pour se remettre les idées en
place.
Le fait le ça fait des beaux cheveux. Le
fait le fait de de prêcher un
endurcissement physique, un
aguérissement, un endurcissement, se
forger un esprit dur dans un corps
affuté,
ça peut être aussi considéré comme ce
que les services de renseignement
décrivent comme la menace vanille.
Hm.
Bah c'est pas Ouais, pour moi c'est un
simplement c'est même pas se dresser,
c'est se redresser. C'est juste
retrouver un petit peu un petit peu
d'alent. Essayer de ressembler à quelque
chose, c'est pas interdit. Mais euh
après oui, malheureusement, je sais bien
que moi je suis vu là sûrement par des
tas de gens qui qui qui ont vu mon nom
euh comme le la bête immonde, le
fascisme, les heures sombres et cetera
et qui me connaissent pas du tout et qui
me connaîtront jamais, qui vont jamais
essayer même de lire un petit peu pour
voir quand même.
Tu vas la faire plusieurs fois, je sens.
Et après on expliquera pourquoi. Parce
que côté côté de ton public si on se
tutoise oui
derrière je me suis fait harceler par
l'ultra droite
Ouais. par les Soraliens et à côté ce
qui était très rigolo par l'ultra gauche
et toute la corte de pseudo journalistes
qui vont avec qui on essayer de me noyer
avec toi. Mais moi je enfin je peux même
pas dire
on n'est pas d'accord, on se tutoie, on
se boxe mais on se respecte. Tout à
fait. Mais moi je sais même pas si ce
sont vraiment mes lecteurs. Il y a des
types voilà des réflexes comme ça
pavlovien. C'est assez effrayant et je
encore une fois je je me tue à dire dans
ce bouquin arrêtez avec la pensée de
partie. Vous êtes là justement pour
mettre en danger ce que vos certitudes.
Si vous prenez tout que vous recrachez
tout vous vous n'existez toujours pas.
Vous parlez à travers à travers ce que
j'ai dit ou ce qu'a dit un autre machin.
Mais
essayez faites faites-vous violence.
C'est aussi ça la guerre. Se faire du
mal, c'est l'épreuve. La confrontation,
c'est aussi celle-là. Euh moi je lis
tous les auteurs justement les
affregauchistes, les Sartres et
compagnie, pas de problème et je pense
qu' enfin c'est nécessaire même.
Est-ce que euh euh prenez et prêchez
l'endurcissement corporel, intellectuel,
le conditionnement dans détecter X ou Y
menace, c'est pas aussi donner des lames
de rasoir à des singes qui ne comprend
qui ne comprennent pas. Est-ce que c'est
pas c'est pas dangereux parce que si on
si je suis votre ton si ça dépend
ton tempme de lecture, on va vers un
effondrement des services publics avec
des zones de non droit où le côté
bestial de l'humanité va ressurgir et on
va redécouvrir le côté
euh euh démoniaque de nos propres
démons, pardon, de la redondance.
Est-ce que c'est pas aussi s'exposer
avoir des gens armés partout n'ayant pas
un moral d'acier ? Parce que c'est plus
simple d'aller s'armer que de s'endurcir
le cerveau. Réagir à froid, calmement,
médiation,
négocier.
Très juste. C'est pas dangereux. Ça pour
le coup, je suis assez d'accord et je
pense qu'il faut vraiment commencer par
se structurer mentalement et se il faut
devenir un adulte mental avant
d'envisager euh autre chose. Avir pour
avoir des armes, il faut être faut être
grand dans sa tête, faut être
responsable, faut comprendre les
conséquences de ses actes et tout ce
genre de choses. Donc c'est tout un
cheminement, un parcours. Évidemment,
faut pas commencer par l'arme à feu. Euh
et après moi, c'est ma position.
J'estime que moi je je suis apte à avoir
des armes. Je pense que beaucoup
d'autres gens le sont.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez comme arme ?
J'ai plusieurs armes de point, quelques
armes longues. Tu calibres ?
Moi, j'ai un calibre 12, j'ai un 223,
j'ai 22. Enfin quelques petits voilà, je
suis un tireur sportif, pas chasseur
mais tireur sportif. Mais je me balade
pas avec, je reste dans le cadre légal.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? F tuer dans le
respect de la loi.
Vous ferait tuer dans le respect de la
loi. Ça veut dire quoi ?
Non mais en fait disons que j'ai pas
envie d'attendre que l'état de droit
l'état de droit vienne à mon secours
quand il m'arrivera des problèmes. Mais
malheureusement je constate qu'il
travaille contre moi aujourd'hui parce
que moi je je pense que je je serais
plus utile pour moi-même pour assurer ma
sécurité si je pouvais faire ce que je
veux me promener avec ce que je veux. Et
malheureusement, l'État ne veut pas que
je fasse ça parce que il veut garder le
monopole de cette violence qu'il qu'il
prétend légitime. Ce qui fait qu'il
m'expose par son incurie actuelle à à
mourir simplement parce que je me
promène et que lui m'a désarmé et qu'il
n'a pas les moyens, il ne se donne pas
les moyens de désarmer d'autres
personnes qui réfléchissent sûrement
beaucoup moins que moi aux conséquences
de leurs actes. Donc ça c'est un
problème.
Vous pensez à qui ? Bah le vous avez 120
coups de couteau par jour à peu près
aujourd'hui. Donc euh
ils sortent deox ces chiffres.
Ça c'était une étude de l'observatoire
de la délinquence euh et des réponses
pénales. Donc qui avait estimé le nombre
euh c'est pas exactement des couteaux,
sont des armes blanches. Toute la
catégorie armes blanche. Donc vous avez
des cuteurs, vous avez enfin voilà tout
ce genre de truc tournevis. Voilà.
Euh donc qui faisait 120 euh il y avait
120 coûts et blessures recensés par jour
avec de telles armes. Il y a 1000
agressions dites gratuites à peu près.
Ça ce sont les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur par jour qui donnent lieu à
une plainte, sachant qu'il y en a
beaucoup plus qui sont pas déclarés
évidemment. Euh donc bah oui, la
situation est assez préoccupante et le
le seul qui est désarmé face à ça, c'est
celui qui s'en remet à l'état de droit.
C'est Robert qui dit "Moi, je respecte
le le code pénal." Et on voit bien que
beaucoup d'autres n'ont pas du tout
cette réflexion là. Ils vont en prison,
ils n'y vont pas, ça change rien. Ils
s'en foutent. Il pour eux, ils ont une
vision extrêmement primaire des choses.
Tu me donnes ta cigarette, je te plante.
Tu me regardes, je te plante. Enfin,
c'est ça s'arrête là. Eux, une vie, ça a
peu d'importance. Et même dans dans
certains milieux tribaux, certains
gangs, pour faire ses preuves, pour
montrer qu'on en a, il faut il faut
montrer que shooter dans la tête du type
qui est inconscient, on peut le faire,
on en est capable, ça fait de vous
quelqu'un. Parce que ces gangs sont
hiérarchisés sur la violence, c'est
comme ça. Donc bah le le mec qui est qui
est gentiment civilisé là au milieu, il
a une espérance de vie qui s'amenuise.
Jouer, on fait une expérience de pensée.
Vous êtes dans le jura.
On aime bien le Jura. Jura magnifique.
On a on a dû compter de 36 mois sur la
table part dans 24 mois.
Tout va bien. 36 ça peut des fois
tourner, faut faire attention mais il
peut être très bien quand même.
Faut aller chez Terrasse.
Ouais.
Et donc le vous connaissez Terrasse
connaisseur
et donc non mais tu crois que tu parles
à qui mon grand ?
Tu tu as des gens qui débarquent chez
toi
en fait c'est des gens qui ont faim.
Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Euh, la question ne s'est jamais ne
s'est jamais présentée, mais je sais
pas,
ça dépend qui sont ces gens, ça dépend
vraiment.
Ça dépend de quoi ?
Bah, je sais pas, moi je veux pas ouvrir
ma porte à 10 types sous prétexte qu'ils
ont la dalle. Enfin,
j'ouvre ma porte à quelqu'un que j'ai
invité. Je suis après moi je suis
quelqu'un plutôt plutôt urbain donc je
peux les dépanner d'un quignon de pain
peut-être pas du compter de 36 mois ça
fait un peu chier mais
pourquoi pas enfin moi ça me la
solidarité je pense gagnerait beaucoup à
être rendue encore une fois à nos
responsabilités parce que comme on
imagine que l'État va y pourvoyer dans
tous les cas qu'on paye assez d'impôts
pour ça on a tendance à mépriser les
gars qui ont des des problèmes qui
souffrent réellement, qui ont un passage
difficile alors que je pense qu'on
aurait on retrouverait le sens de
l'entraide et de la vraie civilité, de
la vraie solidarité si l'État arrêtait
de mal s'en occuper à notre place.
Dans votre bouquin, il y a une dans ton
bouquin ou dans votre bouquin
parce qu'après on va m'accuser de coller
avec l'extrême droite que je suis une
chaîne d'extrême droite que le
journaliste machin spécialisé et crétin
désolé mais parce que à la première la
première interview qu'on a fait
h
j'ai été on a été cyberharcelé
alors on en a pas parlé parce qu'on n
pas du genre à
à se complaire dans
de souffrance et à se plaindre mais à un
niveau
Ouais, j'ai vu j'ai vu passer les Ouais.
les messages effectivement ça a pris des
proportions que moi j'avais jamais vu me
concernant sur aucun autre média.
Ouais. Alors ce qui était rigolo parce
que c'est à la fois d'ultra droite et
l'ultra gauche ils nous ont tombé à bras
raccourci dessus. Ça a été intéressant
pour les cartographies.
Revenons à nos moutons dans la partie
moi président
vous parlez d'abolir toutes les taxes
sauf la TVA.
Oui, c'est un modèle. Alors, on pourrait
à la limite garder un impôt sur le
revenu s'il était l'impôt flat. Chacun
paye le même pourcentage quel que soit
son revenu, mais tout le monde le paye.
Ou alors ouais, une TVA universelle.
Voilà, comme ça on en termine avec ça.
La TVA, c'est l'impôt le plus injuste
qui existe.
Pas forcément. Si euh s'il est modeste,
s'il est modeste et universel,
je sais pas. Je pense que à 3 % de TVA,
si on virait tout ce que je préconise de
virer, ça ça suffit pour payer le le
régalien deux fois. Et vous êtes tué
pour supprimer toutes les aides, toutes
les machins, tout tout.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec l'aide à
l'enfance ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec le pauvre
gamin qui se fait tabasser par des
parents pochetron au fin fond du cul de
la Bourgogne ? Je parle pas de
simplement du bon franco-français
qui tabasse son gamin qu'on fait on fait
comment pour protéger le mom s'il y a
pas d'argent ?
Mais en réalité pour le soustraire de
parents toxiques.
Il y a toujours eu euh et justement il y
avait plus avant des organismes
solidaires qui étaient pour le coup
privés avec des fonds en Grande-Bretagne
il y a eu des des orphelinas comme ça.
Il y a eu tout un t C'est
des philanthropes. Ouais. Ouais. Parce
que oui, mais ça implique quand on a la
responsabilité justement réelle de ce
qui se passe, euh on s'investit plus
là-dedans. Et pourquoi aujourd'hui tous
les Français euh s'éloignent de tous ces
trucs de dons, de caritatif, de machin,
de don du sang et cetera parce que
l'usage qui est fait de cette cette
solidarité forcée les les agace. On sent
bien que c'est fait n'importe comment,
que des sommes délirantes sont dépensées
et que c'est de la mauvaise, c'est de la
c'est ce que disait Nietzs quand il
disait que là, il faut avoir le courage
de contrer sa pitié, de dire parfois
l'aide et est nuisible. Il vaut mieux
avoir le courage d'aider l'autre en ne
l'aidant pas dans certains cas. Encore
une fois, toujours pareil, évidemment,
il y a des cas, voilà qui qui ont qui
ont besoin, qui nécessitent une aide,
mais il y a maintenant, on est dans la
déresponsabilisation totale de
l'individu, on l'accompagne dans son
renoncement à être et euh et
malheureusement ça ça n'aide pas du tout
la société à à comment dire à à
recouvrer son son lien et son allan.
Donc c'est ça que j'essaie de de montrer
dans ce bouquin. Évidemment, ce sont des
propositions assez radicales que aucun
gouvernement n'aura même envisager parce
que le problème de cet appareil, c'est
que il est les ministres sont là pour
défendre chacun leur petit ministère.
Chaque commission défend son truc.
Chacun veut plus de crédit, veut
grossir, veut de l'appareil, veut pas
résoudre des problèmes. Il veut de
l'argent, il veut plus de postes, caser
les copains et cetera. C'est pour ça que
cette machine est de plus en plus grosse
et de moins en moins efficace. Elle nous
coûte de plus en plus cher. On est on en
est réduit à à bosser pour elle. On se
casse le cul pour eux
en permanence. Et avec ça, ils achètent
des cérémonies de d'ouverture à 100
millions. Comment est-ce possible ?
C'est un exemple. Mais comment peut-on
faire ça ? Euh parce que ces gens c'est
pas leur argent. Ils en sont pas
responsables. Ils font n'importe quoi
avec. Fait l'avocat du diable.
Paris plus belle. C'était une belle
cérémonie d'ouverture.
Comment ?
C'était une belle cérémonie d'ouverture.
Vous vous avez trouvé que c'était beau ?
Non non, je croyais que c'est ce que
c'est ce que tu allais dire. Non, le
on a fait un barbecue sur la
Ouais. Non mais enfin
donc le le
100 millions 100 millions
Paris Paris plus belle ville du monde
h
plus belle ville des lumières en plus
ils avaient fait un peu le ménage
c'estàd qu'il y avait plus de rat dans
les villes. Il y avait plus de truc des
cracrac un peu partout.
On met 100 millions sur la table parce
que c'est la France. On veut que ce soit
beau, on veut que ce soit classe. On a
la scène et on est obligé de mettre 22
millions d'euros de sécurité.
On a bouclé tout Paris, on a viré les
Parisiens juste pour montrer Paris sous
son plus beau jour. 100 millions.
Qu'est-ce que c'est 100 millions ?
100 millions c'est beaucoup. C'est
beaucoup 100 millions. Non mais enfin
moi j'aimerais bien voir la ligne de
calcul de ces 100 millions. Comment on
additionne des trucs pour arriver
concrètement à 100 millions. Comment
c'est possible ? Je sais pas le le
c'est c'est le cheval qui a coûté
combien ça coûte le cheval ? S'il coûte
15000 balles, c'est déjà beaucoup par
exemple. Euh je sais pas le cachet là de
de du merde le schtrouf, j'ai oublié son
nom. mec en bleu qui qui chante un truc
là dans son euh peu importe, il avait un
cachet comme ça. Enfin, comment c'est
possible ? Et malheureusement, c'est ça
le gros problème du système, c'est que
ils s'en foutent effectivement.
Flamboyant, c'est c'est ça coûte rien,
c'est l'État machin, enfin euh
quoi qu'il en coûte, on s'en fout. Et
chaque équipe, voilà, Philippe Catherine
et chaque équipe est prête à faire ça.
J'ai rien contre lui mais 100 millions,
c'est beaucoup quand même pour une
soirée. Et malheureusement toutes les
équipes qui arrivent aux manettes
peuvent très bien faire ça. Bruno Lemer,
c'est un auteur de roman érotique. Il a
dépensé 1000 milliards 1000 milliards
1000 milliards 1000 milliards. Il a
endetté nos enfants et peut-être il a
peut-être coulé définitivement ce pays
parce que il était
l'avocé du diable encore parce que vous
parlez tu parles de Bruno mer.
Bon bah, il a acheté la paix sociale à
100 milliard 100 milliards par an pour
éviter que les marchés attaquent la
dette française parce que il y avait le
passage des gilets jaunes qui les a
profondément choqué et que il fallait
absolument que les gens rentrent chez
eux.
Et donc plutôt que de payer sous sa
mandature la dégradation de la note
française, il a préféré faire
h
pour les élections européennes, pour les
Jo, pour tout ça. Il nous a endetté sur
les 60 prochaines années.
Mais il
bah il est bien, il est bien lui. Il est
heureux, il est en Suisse. Je crois
qu'il a il a des projets. Enfin, tout va
bien. En plus, ces types font n'importe
quoi et n'ont jamais en payé le le
moindre début des conséquences. J'ai
calculé dans le bouquin le temps qu'il
lui faudrait s'il faisait la planche
pour rembourser sa dette. J'avais
j'étais 82 millions d'années quelque
chose comme ça. Donc c'est pas lui qui
va payer. C'est vraiment faut piger que
c'est nos enfants. Lui il a sa retraite
à vie. Il aura ses machins, ses
avantages, ses trucs, ses chauffeurs,
c'est euh tout va bien. Non, on la
plonge en France. S'il la fait en
Suisse, ça ira plus vite. On peut
diviser par trois. Euh enfin tout ça
pour dire que eux, ils ont ils se sont
donnés les moyens de jouer, de se faire
plaisir. Voilà. Ils sont ils sont
intouchables. Ils ont J'ai vu que
Darmanin avait une douzaine de gardes du
corps. On sait pas très bien pourquoi.
Mais en tout cas, il les a. Il a ça
toute sa vie, il a ses avantages. C'est
très bien pour eux. Ils ont des bilans
désastreux mais c'est peu importe, ils
seront tous recasés dans des machins
même si c'est une autre équipe qui
gagne. Ça ça changera pas. Le système se
protège très bien de lui-même. Et même
s'ils ont qu'un pouvoir un peu d'apparat
pour certains de dire "Regardez ma
gueule à la télé, j'ai fait telle
proclamation, j'ai donné mon nom, mon
nom au décret, machin mes deux."
C'est pas appliqué mais on s'en fout
pour eux c'est pas grave. Ils sont là,
ils prennent ce qu' à prendre, ils
jouissent du truc. Et en attendant, on
voit bien ce qui va se passer
maintenant, c'est que la solution qui
qui qui semble que tout le monde a l'air
de de vouloir partager, c'est pas il
faut supprimer le ministre de la
culture, il faut supprimer ceci, cela,
il faut couper ses dépenses aberrentes.
Non, la seule solution qu'on envisage,
c'est comment trouver des sous. On va
taxer, je sais pas, les mecs qui
vapotent, les les mecs qui ont qui ont
plus de sous que les autres. On va
trouver des moyens d'augmenter la la
puissance de vol et de raquettes. Et
malheureusement beaucoup de Français
pensent que c'est une bonne idée tant
que ça ne nous concerne pas. les
raquettes, pourquoi pas dire
solidarité entraide pourquoi pas dire
c'est beaucoup mieux dans un communiqué
mais concrètement quand on vous prend de
l'argent que vous voulez pas donner
pourquoi payer des la TVA pour et tes
impôts sur la vente de tes bouquins avec
comme c'est un produit culturel c'est un
peu moins cher d'ailleurs. Ouais,
faut il faut remercier les les
socialistes qui étaient pas content de
payer le salaire des infirmières, des
des plombiers, pas des plombiers pardon,
des des sapeurs pompiers euh à domicile.
Je je serais content de le payer parce
que ça de de l'insuline pour les
diabétiques. Ouais, mais on aura
toujours besoin de payer le salaire de
de des gens, des artisans qui s'occupent
de nous, de quand on sera soigné, on
aura dans mon dans mon monde dans le la
dystopie au Burton ou l'utopie au
Burton, je sais pas ce qu'on comment ça
dépend où on se place sur les chiquers,
mais on aura toujours besoin de payer
euh les prestations, mais c'est pas pour
autant que qu'elles seront moins bonnes.
Là, c'est un mythe français ça.
Tu as déjà été te faire soigner à Dubaï
ou aux États-Unis ?
Non, non, non. J'ai jamais eu d'ennui de
santé significatif. Imagine-toi, tu
connais le le tarif ?
Ouais, c'est cher. Ouais,
c'est cher. De combien ? Oh,
je sais rien. J'ai jamais été j'ai
jamais foutu les pieds aux États-Unis,
mais on dit que c'est cher. On dit que
c'est cher.
Est-ce que ça Est-ce que ça peut nous
coûter plus cher que le système de santé
français ?
160000 € pour
Ouais, mais combien on va payer sur une
existence complète ?
700 dollars la dose d'insuline 35 en
France.
Ouais. Ouais. En France, combien on va
payer sur notre vie durant euh le coût
de la santé publique ? 1 € sur 2 qui est
produit chaque année, ça représente des
des sommes qui sont complètement
délirantes. On nous dit il pay on paye
les routes mais les routes on les a payé
150 fois. Enfin, c'est ça le problème du
de des trucs publics, c'est que ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher que ce que ça vaut.
Et parce que il y a le le l'appareil
goinfre intermédiaire, il y a
l'administration, les postes, les
machins et c'est pas censé être
efficace, c'est censé être gros. censé
bouffer se gaver de crédit et augmenté.
Donc euh c'est tout ça est un problème.
Euh mais ça veut pas dire qu'évidemment
on aura toujours besoin de certains
services et on les payera nous-même et
je pense ça ira mieux et on évitera au
passage de payer le salaire de je sais
pas de Léa Salamé de Nagi euh qui sont à
mon avis
d'Arté. Je je critique pas leur travail
du président d'Arté. J'ai j'ai vu passer
ça. HRC Caron a raison. Je le déclare je
le déclare solennellement. Je j'ai pas
dit souvent. tout un tas de trucs d'
il a il a raison. Bah en tout cas sur
ça, il a il a raison et mais c'est ces
trucs là, moi enfin ça fait des années
que je je je dis ça, il y a des enf les
conflits d'intérêt mais l'État est un
conflit d'intérêt, c'est une machine. La
République a distribué des privilèges.
Elle ne fait plus que ça en permanence.
On nous dit on a aboli la monarchie
machin. Mais que fait l'État aujourd'hui
? le fait qu'il y ait des je sais pas
des différences fiscales, des des
accords différents, des impôts
différenciers, c'est ce sont des
privilèges. Et le le la moindre
subvention, le moindre euro que vous
prenez à quelqu'un pour le donner à
quelqu'un d'autre, c'est un privilège.
Et comme moi je ne veux pas qu'on me
prenne mon argent, je ne consens pas à
l'impôt, je ne contracte pas, et bien on
va me forcer à le faire.
On te on te le prend pas, tu cotises.
Oui. Bah oui. Enfin, j'ai pas le choix.
Si je veux pas euh je veux pas payer le
salaire de l'S à l'AM. Euh bah j'ai je
le paye quand même. Là j'ai pris un café
tout à l'heure, je mets TVA et là c'est
comme ça. Je peux pas
payer ton café commencer
je peux faire autre. Non, j'ai pas payé
ton café. J'ai payé un café avant.
Ah ça va al
C'est toi qui a payé le salaire de la
Salamé.
[Musique]
Nous on est content de payer le salaire
des profs même s'ils sont sous-payés.
Ouais, je suis d'accord. Dans ton
bouquin, tu dis il faut ér le le l'école
publique.
Ouais, mais pas les profs. Ça veut pas
dire queon jette les profs par la
fenêtre. Euh c'est nécessaire les profs,
il faut enfin
si on peut pas payer l'école privée ?
Ah mais si on peut payer l'école
publique, on pourra payer l'école
privée.
Ça enfin
tu connais le système américain ?
Ouais, assez peu. Assez peu. Non.
Renseigne-toi ça ça va te faire
peut-être changer ton prisme de lecture.
Revenons, on va essayer de te
déconcentrer un petit peu. Revenons aux
Jeux Olympiques puisque tu abordes le
sujet.
Tu es beaucoup plus connecté avec ce qui
est appelé l'extrême droite ou
l'ultradroite que nous. Ça a été perçu
comment la cérémonie d'ouverture ?
Il y a eu des belles choses en gros le
discours que j'ai entendu le plus, il y
a eu des belles choses et il y a eu un
schtroumf à moitié à poil au milieu d'un
d'un parterre de de enfin un truc une
allégorie de la scène enfin ça j'ai avec
une couille qui dépasse paraît-il j'ai
je me souviens enfin honnêtement j'ai
pas zoomé j'ai pas je tenais pas
spécialement en détail et je savais que
ça allait coûter cher c'était surtout ça
le le le la préoccupation et évidemment
ça a coûté très cher ça a coûté 100
millions. Donc on l'a dit, 22 pour la
sécurité. Bref,
après voilà, c'est ça fait partie du
monde politique aujourd'hui, le
spectacle. Mais qu'on mette 100 millions
à la cérémonie d'ouverture ou pour la
rénovation de je sais pas quoi ou les
plans le le la politique de la ville
machin, c'est toujours à peu près le
même spectacle. C'est du pognon balancé
par la fenêtre. Monsieur Moyen se dit
"Ah l'État est moyen." Il oublie que
l'État c'est ses poches et il est
content. Il se dit "On fait quelque
chose ? C'est en France, c'est ça la
logique. On fout un énorme paquet de
pognons sur un problème en disant "C'est
bon, c'est réglé, ça va."
Mais euh on voit on voit pas qu'il y a
plus de pognon, qu'il y a plus on est
dans on creuse là, on est en train de de
creuser très très fort. On sait pas
comment on va faire du tout parce que
tous les toute l'administration
verrouille pour ne rien lâcher. Euh les
voleurs s'agrippent à leur butin. Il y a
un système parasitaire de la quantité
d'étages et je sais pas comment ça va
finir. parasitaire, ils sont pas tous
mais il y a il y a sûrement des
fonctionnaires qui ont une rigueur
exceptionnelle qui sont général
qui veulent servir. Voilà, tout à fait.
Mais l'appareil est ainsi fait que euh
c'est pas c'est pas comme ça que les les
gens probes euh déjà souvent ils sont
c'est pas ceux qui montent le plus haut.
Il faut être pour réussir dans ce dans
ce truc, il faut être assez vicieux, le
voyer. Enfin voilà, il faut c'est comme
la politique, c'est un concours de
psychopathe et ceux qui gagnent sont pas
les les gens les les plus recommandables
de la terre. Et malheureusement, on
continue à se passionner pour ça. Mais
ça aussi la la politique, c'est une
machine formidable de diversion.
On on
conditionne le pays à s'entretuer entre
communautés, entre machins justement
parce que cet état à ce pouvoir de
distribuer des privilèges, des prébandes
en disant eux ils ont gueulé plus fort,
ils ont bloqué telle cru qu'ils peuvent
être chiants, on va leur donner un peu
plus et ça tient comme ça. Mais ça c'est
pas une société, c'est un truc qui est
en train d'exploser.
Revenons au bouquin guerre et revenons à
Laurent Aubertone, conseil matrimonial.
Robert et sa Roberette. Qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce chapitre ? Non, sans
déconner. Mais c'est pareil, un constat
les décriv décrit décrit le le
il y a énormément de gens aujourd'hui
qui peignent énormément à à trouver
quelqu'un d'à peu près valable, à se
comporter déjà de manière à peu près
valable et à euh à fonder une famille, à
avoir une vie conjugale normale et à et
à rester ensemble et à traverser les
épreuves à plusieurs. enfin faire ce qu'
ce qui existe depuis assez souvent et je
trouve que les rapports entre les
siècles, je l'avais c'était dans mon
précédent bouquin raisonnablement
sexiste toujours aux éditions de Magnus,
j'avais développé développé ce ce
constat et
malheureusement on est victime de
l'époque. Il y a ce caractère immédiat
on peut tout faire sans conséquence.
Sauf que non, c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche. On a une réputation, on a des
choses en jeu.
Est-ce que tu es pour ou contre
l'avortement ?
Euh, enfin, j'ai pareil, j'ai jamais été
confronté au à la problématique.
Est-ce que tu as contre l'euthanasie ?
Euh, c'est alors c'est exactement
pareil. J'ai pas j'ai plutôt tendance
enfin je suis assez méfiant par rapport
à ce que ça pourrait devenir si on
donnait ça encore une fois la au
magistère, à l'appareil d'État.
Est-ce que tu es pour ? Tu as fini ta
réponse ou pas ?
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais.
Est-ce que tu es pour ou contre
l'adoption pour un couple homosexuel ?
L'adoption en tant que telle déjà,
enfin, c'est quelque chose que j'ai
vraiment du mal à imaginer à à titre
personnel l'adoption
parce que moi, enfin, vraiment, j'ai du
mal à concevoir l'existence sans
l'affiliation.
Imagine-toi, imagine-toi, tu es stérile.
Ouais. Ouais. Non, mais je Mais
oui, ta femme est stérile.
C'est un exercice d'imagination. Tu
parles dans ton bouquin de transmettre
les valeurs, chevalesque le les valeurs.
Pourquoi pas transmettre à un pauvre
gamin
qui a plus de parents
transmettre tes valeurs.
C'est je m'adresse pas qu'au pauvre
gamin, mais ce que j'essaie de faire
dans mes bouquins, c'est aussi ça, de
transmettre au-delà de au-delà de de
moi-même, au-delà de donc peut-être que
j'aurais fait la démarche, j'en sais
rien, mais je suis pas du tout dans la
situation, je vois que certains le sont
et je voilà, c'est c'est des trucs très
individuels, c'est des c'est des choix à
eux. qui leur appartiennent. J'ai j'ai
dû je je suis pas dans leur dans leur
existence pour pour dire qu'ils ont à le
faire ou pas.
Revenons revenons à Robert.
Ouais.
L'agence matrimoniale Auertoone.
Qu'est-ce qu'il conseille ?
Et ben Robert se dit souvent pourquoi
Robert ?
Robert parce que bah c'est c'est le
Jacques c'est bien aussi.
Ouais pourquoi pas ? et George enfin
n'importe quel prénom traditionnel ça
marche.
C'est quoi un prénom traditionnel ?
Bah al Robert c'est tout à fait
traditionnel. J'ai prénom
enérant. Enérant c'est un peu moins
traditionnel en Guérant. On est déjà
dans un registre
Versailles la messe et cetera. On est Oh
si si si déjà Oh si si ça dit beaucoup
les prénoms quand même. Et là on est
déjà dans
c'est c'est pas la même chose. Robert
c'est monsieur moyen vraiment très
représentatif de la de la classe moyenne
un peu moins. Euh et Robert souvent ne
comprend pas pourquoi il n'intéresse pas
Robert et Jacqueline et Mirey et cetera.
Pourquoi tu as pas pris Karim comme
prénom ?
Karim, c'est un petit peu moins dans mon
esprit rétrograde et extrême droitiste,
c'est un peu moins représentatif
de la de la France traditionnelle. Mais
bon, les choses les choses évoluent.
Peut-être que Karim sera où est déjà le
Robert le Robert de demain. Bien que le
grand emplacement soit une théorie qui
n'existe pas, ça peut arriver. Mais ce
que je veux dire, c'est que Robert n'a
donc ne ne comprend pas, n'a pas de
recul sur lui-même, ne comprend pas
pourquoi il n'est pas regardé, il n'est
pas envisagé. et je je ramène l'individu
face à à l'image qu'il renvoie, à ce
qu'il est. Euh malheureusement, quand on
délègue tout à l'État et à d'autres et
qu'on attend tout de la politique et des
autres, qu'on se dit il y a un miracle,
ça va nous sauver machin, on pense plus
du tout à soi, à ses responsabilités. Et
si on veut exister, il faut un statut,
il faut un accomplissement, il faut une
réputation, il faut ces ces choses-là.
Donc il faut faire des efforts, se
redresser, c'est un bon début, perdre
deux trois tissus mou et montrer qu'on a
qu'on a une valeur, qu'on a une valeur
individuelle, qu'on mérite d'être d'être
envisagé par la jante féminine et
inversement. Euh et déjà quand on se
construit soi-même, ça ça nous permet
d'avoir des des possibilités un peu plus
développées. Donc c'est le début de
l'agence matrimoniale, c'est de dire à
Robert ne pas attendre tout de Robert
mais de commencer par lui.
Est-ce que tu es homophobe ?
Homophobe
dis euh cette grosse tente qui se
vernissait les ongles.
Non, c'est pas de l'homophobie. Non non,
dans mon idée non, pas du tout. Euh je
crois enfin c'est
plus tu parlais de Guering, je crois
bien.
Oui oui, c'est Gering. Oui oui
effectivement bah qui était décrit comme
ça. Euh bon euh il était après il était
euh complètement assommé par les la
godéine ou je sais la morphine, je sais
plus quoi. Euh bref, moi je non j'ai pas
j'ai pas la peur de de l'homosexualité.
Pas du tout. Euh
qu'est-ce que tu reproches alors ? Tu
décris le lobby LGBTQ. euh d'une façon
très agressive.
Euh je moi ce qui me pr enfin ce qui me
ton doigt de la bouche,
pardon, ce qui me gêne avec cet
activisme euh notamment aujourd'hui,
c'est l'activisme enfin homo homosexuel,
les militants la cause homosexuelle
actup et cetera sont quasiment
ringardisés, ont disparu un peu du
paysage au profit plutôt du militante.
Trans, le transactivisme aujourd'hui a
complètement pris euh la les parts de
marché. C'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il y
a des des sissions internes à ces
mouvements LGBT, Q R code plus, je sais
plus le le truc exact, vous me
pardonnerez.
Et et
euh bah comme tous les activismes, le
problème c'est que ils vont être assez
nuisibles parce qu'ils vont offrir à des
populations
jeunes une
une identité de substitution. un million
suis notre nos principes adhère à la
cause et tu seras quelqu'un, tu veux
exister comme ça dans ton petit groupe
social universitaire.
Oui. Ah ben j'assume complètement. Moi
j'ai je suis enfin je suis quelqu'un,
j'interprète, j'ai mes biaiss, il y a
aucun problème avec ça. Et bah ça va
cloisonner dans des identités nuisibles
qui font partie de l'identité sectaire
beaucoup de jeunes individus
et les privés de de repères un peu plus
réalistes.
C'est encore ton interprétation ?
Oui, complètement assumé. Euh je voilà,
je pense que ces mouvements activistes
sont dangereux en tout cas pour le volet
transactiviste
parce que ils vont persuader des jeunes
qui vont pas bien que une solution à
leur problème serait de remettre en
cause leur leur nature. Il y a
évidemment des problèmes hormonaux, il y
a des problèmes biologiques, il y a des
anomalies, ça existe, ça a toujours
existé. Euh
peut-être un peu plus maintenant avec
les percateurs endocés. Il y en a sans
doute beaucoup plus en effet, mais la
réponse scientifique et médicale doit
être à mon avis bien plus prudente que
ça de dire c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
problèmes de cet ordre que il y a la
baguette magique du changement de sexe
qui va tout régler avec le bon
traitement. Enfin, ce sont des trucs
extrêmement graves et et lourds qui qui
font des des victimes coup et que la
science permet de ça me paraît aberrant.
Mais oui,
on connait pas encore le sujet. On va
essayer de creuser pour comprendre un
peu plus la chose. Revenons à ton
bouquin.
H
le passage que je t'ai lu avec
il faut les faire péter, une grosse
charge de TNT sous leur fondation, c'est
au propre, au figurer.
Ah, on parle de la on parle de de des
idées de la de la morale dominante, des
mots d'ordre. Et c'est ça qui est qui
est dangereux. Par exemple, l'idée de
d'égalité. Il y a des inégalités, il
faut l'égalité. Ça c'est une folie.
C'est comme ça qu'on pour le bien de
tous.
D'après ton prisma de lecture, c'est un
nivellement par le bas. Ben en fait,
c'est une un refus total de la vie parce
que la vie, elle se construit justement
dans l'inégalité,
euh dans le danger, dans les preuves,
dans tout un tas de de choses. Euh si on
a justement enfin la compétition pour la
vie, c'est celle d'exister un peu plus
que les autres, de d'acquérir un un
niveau un peu un peu meilleur que le
nôtre, un statut supérieur. Et c'est
comme ça que la sélection natur, enfin
la sélection naturelle ou la sélection
sexuelle a lieu. Et
imaginer qu'on doit aniler ça,ir
complètement les différences entre les
individus. C'est un raisonnement
qui va conduire fatalement à un arbitre
tout-puissant. Donc une tyrannie, une
administration qui va euh estimer que
s'il y a une égalité, c'est qu'il y a
une injustice. Euh ça peut pas être une
égalité de je sais pas d'envie,
d'aptitude, de de caractère. C'est
forcément une injustice. Donc il faut
prendre au salot qui est un petit peu
au-dessus pour donner à celui qui est un
peu au-dessous et comme ça le monde va
mieux. Mais non, là on y complètement
enfin même chez les les primates ou dans
dans même chez les chiens d'ailleurs,
c'est ça fonctionne pas comme ça. Il y a
des différences,
il y a des différences constatées. Mais
non, mais ça c'est enfin tous les
animaux c'est c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne. Les les
c'est c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne.
C'est un raisonnement à l'emportepièce.
Ah non mais les animaux ne se
reproduisent pas par hasard. par exemple
euh il y a il y a une sélection sexuelle
qui est basée sur des critères qu'on
peut objectiver que les les étologues
ont on mre fois montré chez l'être
humain c'est la même chose. Justement
Robert n'est pas la cible privilégiée de
Ginette parce que il est Robert.
Et comment tu'expliques les couples
homosexuels chez Albatros et chez le
pingouin ? Ah mais non, mais ça c'est je
veux dire la sélection sexuelle, elle
n'a pas à être euh
c'est pas c'est pas un truc c'est pas un
modèle mathématique. Euh ce qui compte
c'est ce qui se passe à à long terme. On
peut je sais pas euh
je peux très bien décider de ne pas me
reproduire. J'aurais pu mourir avant de
le faire. il aurait pu m'arriver des tas
de trucs, je serais quand même la même
personne machin, mais c'est pas il y a
des il y a des choses euh qui sont euh
différentes, qui sont euh qu'on a du mal
à expliquer, que les scientifiques même
ont du mal à expliquer, mais il
n'empêche qu'au bout du compte, il y a
des principes de sélection du
partenaire, même chez les couples
homosexuels.
Alors, comment tu as sélectionné ta
partenaire ? Ah bah parce que c'est la
plus parfaite créature de l'univers. Moi
j'ai eu de la chance mais non c'est pas
possible.
Euh bah moi c'est ce que je pense.
Parfait.
C'est encore un biais. Voilà. On a des
billets. Voilà. On a des billets. C'est
terrible.
Et non, enfin voilà, je j'ai beaucoup de
chance mais il y a il y a des raisons
qui expliquent ça chez l'être humain.
C'est particulier parce que on est des
animaux domestiques et malheureusement
une des caractéristiques de la
domestication non est tous un peu. Euh
c'est
pourquoi dans ton bouquin, il y a
toujours cet aspect, je dirais il faut
être primitif, il faut revenir à
l'instat primitif du loup, être un
chasseur, il
revenir revenir à ce côté euh dangereux
que la personne en face, il faut bien
qu'elle comprenne que je suis dangereux.
Si elle se permet de rentrer dans mon
cercle privatif, elle doit assumer le
fait que je peux être dangereux ou mon
clan, mon groupe peut être dangereux.
Mais il faut être dangereux. Ouais,
c'est indispensable. Sinon euh bah on
peut vous marcher dessus, on fait ce
qu'on veut avec vous.
Imagine-toi.
Mais toi, tu es toi tu es dangereux.
Toi,
toi, tu as été moins doté que la nature
que moi.
Ouais.
Si je suis dangereux avec toi, tu sais
ce qui peut t'arriver ?
Ouais.
Tu le prends comment ? La différence
c'est que il y a des lois, il y a un
code de civilité, on est humain,
on peut on doit échanger, on peut se
mettre d'accord sur le fait qu'on soit
pas d'accord. Pourquoi toujours prêcher
ce côté ?
Non, mais
il faut être
justement pas parce qu'on est dangereux
qu'on est obligé testostérone.
Non, je crois pas. C'est pas c'est pas
parce qu'on est beau, j'avais fait des
des d'un bilan sanguin il y a quelques
temps qui était assez excellent et qui
était même plutôt plutôt flatteur à ce
niveau-là. Mais c'est pas parce qu'on
est euh
c'est pas parce qu'on est dangereux que
qu'on est obligé d'être un bourrin. Au
contraire, on a voilà, moi j'ai comme tu
disais tout à l'heure par exemple, j'ai
des armes plein plein mes mes mon
armoire forte. Si des types viennent me
demander à manger, je vais pas tirer
dessus. On va parlementer d'abord, on va
discuter, on va peut-être boire un
verre, je sais pas. Euh justement, si on
est en capacité d'être dangereux, on
doit avoir des responsabilités d'autant
plus grandes. Nos nos responsabilités
d'hommes libres, elles sont là. Euh les
animaux, ce qui les sauve, ce qui fait
qu'ils existent, c'est qu'ils ont cette
capacité à se défendre. euh le le fameux
lion de la fable de la fontaine. On lui
lime les les griffes et les dents et il
se fait bouffer par des chien parce que
il accepte de se de se désarmer. Et
malheureusement, c'est ce qu'on a fait.
On a confié la responsabilité de de
notre sécurité à une machine qui sera
pas toujours là quand il faudra.
Pourquoi tu dis quand il faudra ? Tu
t'attends à quoi ? Bah n'importe quoi.
Enfin, il faut toujours, on peut pas
prédire mais on on peut prévoir quand
même parce que bah sinon euh alerte,
il faut être vigilant. Ouais. Sobre et
vigilant, c'est la clé euh c'est la clé
de tout. Je sais plus qui disait ça.
C'est peut-être bien dans la Bible en
plus. Mais ouais, il faut faire
attention. Il faut faire attention.
Évidemment qu'un nous sommes encore une
fois on a je parle souvent de nos
instincts parce que on est fait pour un
environnement ancestral qui était un
danger permanent beaucoup plus dangereux
que ce qu'on a connu aujourd'hui. Et
comme on est créature domestique, on est
bien au chaud dans notre confort, on se
rend pas compte, on se rend plus compte
que la menace peut revenir très vite et
très fort et on est totalement à poil.
On n'est pas capable de supporter une
nuit dans la rue. Euh le frigo vide, le
téléphone qui tombe en panne,
l'électricité qui tombe. On on peut plus
faire face. On est en panique s'il y a
pas les flics au bout du fil ou le on a
on n' pas les notions de survie
élémentaire. On a tout délégué, tout
abandonné et ça nous met dans une
situation vraiment préoccupante. On est
littéralement les vaches dans les
tables, il y a plus de foin, le
propriétaire est mort, il vient plus.
Merde, bah elles vont crever. Voilà. Et
c'est la situation dans laquelle on
s'est on s'est placé
qui vient ouvrir les portes vaches.
Est-ce que c'est toi Alan dans cette
histoire ? Est-ce que tu te testimes en
tant que lanceur d'alerte ?
Peut-être, je sais pas. Ouais, pourquoi
pas ? Pourquoi pas ? Je je je balance
des bouteilles dans la mer et
j'écris, comme disait Valérie pour
quelqu'un qui viendra après en espérant
que je sais pas, il y en a un que ça
inspire. J'avais un prof qui nous avait
dit ça une fois à la dans l'ampille, un
prof d'anthropologie qui avait dit euh
vous êtes 300, la plupart en auront rien
à vont pas faire attention, mais
il y a peut-être une personne dans cette
salle qui sera marquée par ce que je
vais dire et ça va changer sa vie et il
va à son tour apporter des réflexions
intéressantes et cetera. Et ben donc là,
peut-être que sur tous les gars qui sont
en train de m'injurier, il y en a
peut-être un qui va ouvrir le bouquin
qui va se dire "Ah, j'ai quand même un
peu changer ma façon de voir et
peut-être que ça va enrichir son
développement et que il il transmettra
des trucs à ses gauches." J'en sais
rien. Il faut essayer en tout cas à mon
avis de de faire quelque chose.
Question internet. Laurent Aberton de
points. La tradition maintient du feu ou
culte des cendres ?
quoi les deux mon général on peut pas
c'est c'est pas interdit de c'est pas
interdit de penser à tous ceux qui ont
qui nous ont précédé qui eux ont
accompli leur mission donc ça veut dire
qu'ils ont été dangereux ils ont su
trouver Robert à chaque fois et ils ont
su ils ont su maintenir le fil de la vie
jusqu'à nous donc ils sont à la fois la
cendre et le feu et nous on a le
flambeau. C'est dommage de l'éteindre.
Moi, c'est mon c'est c'est ça peut
arriver mais je pense qu'il faut essayer
de le au moins de le donner dans les
dans les conditions dont on lesquelles
on l'a reçu.
Question internet. Qu'est-ce que c'est
pour lui l'humanité ?
L'humanité c'est un terme à la con, ça
veut pas dire grand-chose. On est une
espèce euh on est une espèce animale
encore une fois très étrange parce que
la seule qui s'est domestiqué elle-même
et qui ne voit pas, qui ne pense pas les
conséquences de ça, la domestication
reste un angle mort complet pour nos
intellectuels. on fait de la sociologie,
on fait des tas de trucs, mais on se
rend pas compte que la dérégulation, par
exemple, de nos instincts, nos instincts
alimentaires, nos instincts sexuels qui
sont complètement déréglés euh par
rapport à ce qu'ils ont dû être à l'état
de nature, euh voilà, tout ces choses,
enfin ça nous ça nous concerne au
premier chef, ces comportements qui qui
sont parfois très préjudiciables, la
pétence pour les récompenses à court
terme, l'incapacité à nous projeter, la
juvénilité prolongée jusqu'à la fin de
notre vie. euh cette capacité qu'on a à
se divertir, enfin tout un tas de choses
qui sont vraiment notre comportement et
qu'on refuse de de regarder en face.
Pourquoi pourquoi on se fait posséder en
quelque sorte ? Quand est-ce qu'on
devient un homme ?
Je dirais quand on devient adulte. Mais
c'est rare. C'est de plus en plus rare
parce qu'on peut ne pas le faire. C'est
ça l'intérêt de l'animal domestique,
c'est que le chien, il a pas besoin de
devenir adulte. Il a pas besoin de
prendre sa vie en main puisqu'il a il a
un maître qui lui donne qui remplit le
qui veille à ses besoins primaires mais
nous c'est exactement pareil
de parler de clé par ce que tu connais
vraiment
tu connais mais c'est exactement ce qui
se passe. Le le chien tu lui donnes à
bouffer. Oui mais parce que c'est des
races qui sont sélectionnées. C'est très
particulier. Clébar il y a des clés
barres. Si tu as une attitude trop
dominante, ça les laisse toujours à leur
place de petit chiot et tu as des
comportements de chiot chez le chien
adulte parce que il y a un trouble
éducatif qui vient de du maître et donc
du pack. H
c'est ça.
Tu parles d'hormone d'ailleurs dans ton
bouquin. Tu as une formation
d'endocrinologue ou
Ah non non, j'ai pas de formation. Moi,
je me suis démerdé. J'ai lu des bouquins
là-dessus sur les enfin les la biologie
et cetera. L'endctrinologie, j'ai pu en
lire je sais pas un paquet de des
traités à la con. Enfin, je te je
saurais pas te sortir, il faudrait que
je regarde ma bibliothèque. Mais ouais,
j'ai essayé de piger les mécanismes qui
qui parce que les hormones ça fait tout.
Euh enfin ce qui fait mon humeur là
actuellement, si je reviens demain, on
refait l'interview, je dirais peut-être
pas la même chose. Je suis pas
propriétaire de mon de de de ma
personne. On est possédé par ces petites
choses.
Question internet. Puis a les
philosophies, ça aide à comprendre, non
?
Ouais, la philosophie. Ouais. Question
internet. Si le collectif est si
important, en quoi se préparer à tuer
son prochain est plus important que de
se préparer à collaborer avec son
prochain ? B c'est pareil, on peut faire
les deux. Euh enfin moi j'ai des armes à
feu chez moi. C'est pas pour autant que
je je pisse sur les gens que je croise.
Enfin, je j'ai des bonnes relations de
voisinage avec tout le monde. J'ai
plutôt à chaque fois je fais plutôt
bonne impression. Les gens m'aiment
bien. Ils s'imaginent que justement je
suis un type un peu spécial mais non,
enfin je suis plutôt équilibré et normal
et assez calme.
Tu parles, tu parles dans ton bouquin de
Takia.
C'est quoi la takia ?
Est-ce que les gens d'extrême droite
sont en train de faire une takia ?
Peut-être que certains le font. Moi
honnêtement, j'en connais pas. Je
connais assez déjà connais assez peu de
gens. Bah le type qui va essayer de
dissimuler ses intentions derrière un
côté lisse, je sais pas un côté pass qui
met la tête droite,
qui s'habille correctement, qui présente
bien, qui dit bonjour, qui machin et qui
en secret prépare, je sais pas, se
prépare à faire sauter le monde.
Peut-être que ça existe. Moi ça m'étonne
souvent qui est qui est assez peu par
rapport justement au nombre d'individus
qui se disent d'ultradooite
suivi par les renseignements machin et
cetera. Ça m'étonne qu'il y ait peu
finalement de brévic français parce que
dans
peut-être que nos services de
renseignement fonctionnent bien parce
que là on a chopé qui était armé
jusqu'aux dents.
Ouais mais en général les gars qui sont
chopés sont de fameux gogol qui enfin
qui sont très amateurs et
en Allemagne en Allemagne on a chopé
qu'il y avait des pièces d'or qui avait
des armes partout.
Non mais alors c'est possible qu'il y a
des gars qui soient qui soient
organisés. Euh est-ce que tu participes
pas un peu toi et d'autres
à armer ces parce que ils
comprennent pas tes textes ou ils
interprètent leur texte ?
C'est ça c'est ça c'est le le enfin
c'est le dilemme éternel. On n'est pas à
l'abri d'être
d'être lu par des cons. Oui mais ça mais
le problème c'est que si on fait ça on
rentre dans cette logique Walt Disney en
disant je l'avais fait avec Utoya à
Brevic. Euh, on m'avait dit "Mais ce
bouquin, on est dans la tête du tueur et
euh on sait pas ce que vous vous
pensez." Et je lui dis "Mais c'est ce
que lui pense, c'est j'ai fait une
enquête sur lui, j'ai retranscrit sa
pensée et j'ai pas voulu mettre au début
attention, l'auteur se dégage des
machins. Il est très méchant Brévic." Ça
paraît
Il est quand même très méchant Brévic.
Ben oui, mais ça para voilà mais ça
paraît assez évident et je me dis que si
quelqu'un ne se dit pas ça par rapport à
ce personnage, je peux plus rien pour
lui. C'est un cas psychiatrique et
malheureusement il y en a. On pourra
jamais éviter ça mais enfin
n'importe qui peut peut générer ce genre
de cingl. Ils ont pas besoin de moi pour
ça je pense.
Question internet
c'est quoi pour lui la menace ?
La menace, c'est que cet état de
domestication, donc d'attente, euh de
passivité euh bah finissent par nous
coûter très cher parce qu'on a tout
délégué dans ce maître. Et si le maître
euh comme parce qu'il est victime de
lui-même, de son de son de son de Bruno
Leire et d'autres, s'il éclate en plein
vol, on sera fort dépourvu parce que la
bise va venir très fort et on aura pas
du tout préparé ça. On se sera fié à un
système qui paraît solide. mais qui
paraît seulement. Et ça c'est oui, ça
c'est une vraie une vraie menace. Et la
menace pour moi c'est que les gens
continuent à ignorer à ignorer cet état.
Pourquoi il paraît ?
Bah parce que il a l'air fort. Comme je
disais tout à l'heure, essaie de pas
payer tes impôts, essaie de pas payer
ton amende et avec toi il sera fort
parce que nous on est réceptif, on est
des citoyens dociles bien élevés. On a
peur des huissiers, de la visite des
flics à 6h du matin, des convocations,
des machins. Donc on on fait tout bien
comme il faut. Euh c'est c'est mais il
est fort parce que justement il y a pas
de de menace constituée à lui opposer.
Il est fort en un point précis. Moi s'il
m'envoie les troupes d'assaut à 6h du
matin. Oui, là il est fort physique
je pourrais je pense que je pourrais
résister un petit peu. Bon euh pour pour
euh pour l'honneur
mais tu es très tiré avec des gars du
raid ou du GGN toi. Oh, j'ai fait
quelques trucs qui qui sont pas mal qui
c'estàd pré
Non, bah non, mais je peux je peux pas
je peux pas trahir mes mes contacts.
Mais non, non, mais après euh
voir les dragons parachut
encore une fois, ce serait vraiment pour
l'honneur euh pour pas partir tout seul.
C'est l'honneur, il y a à résister à ça.
Non, non, mais c'est une plaisanterie.
S'ils viennent, je leur donnerai un bout
de vieux compté, je partirai avec eux
comme tout le monde. Mais euh Non, ce
que je veux dire, c'est qu'on peut rien
faire contre cette force si elle est
organisée, qu'elle frappe en un point
précis.
Euh elle est elle est plus forte, c'est
comme ça le Mais si les choses merdent
de manière un peu globale, c'est comme
le système bancaire. Si les gens vont
tous prendre leur argent en même temps,
ça va pas aller. C'est la même chose
avec les forces de l'ordre, avec l'État,
avec l'appareil répressif. Il y a un
moment où s'il y a une merde un peu plus
générale, ça peut ne pas tenir. Et et
là, pour le coup, dans le grand chacun
pour soi, les les policiers, ils iront
pas protégé Laurent Fabus en premier, je
pense.
Ou Gabriel,
c'est triste pour lui. H
Donc, les gens te lisent, les gens sont
au courant que tu as une conduite
résiliente avec ton prisme de lecture
qui t'est propre.
Si ça calanche tel que tu l'anticipes,
tu penses pas que les gens ils vont dire
"Ok à ta porte, on demand des bouts de
compté ou peut-être quelques quelques
quelques balles ?"
Ouais, c'est possible mais ça
m'étonnerait parce que je vis dans une
campagne très reculée. On a un petit
réseau de voisinage et il y a pas
beaucoup de gens qui viennent là et
après voilà, on sera
on pourra s'entendre avec les gens de
bonne volonté, de bonne réputation sans
problème comme on l'a toujours fait.
Quelle est ta formation personnelle pour
la survie ?
C'est très j'ai pour le coup c'est pas
très élaboré. Moi j'ai vraiment les
bases. J'ai un puit, j'ai un peu de
bouffe, j'ai je vis vraiment au milieu
de la campagne. C'est quoi un peu de
bouffe ? C'est une semaine, 2 semaines,
3 semaines, un mois, 6 mois.
Ouais, c'est raisonnable d'avoir quand
même pour quelques semaines. Mais mais
j'ai j'ai pas l'anti l'abri antiatomique
avec les les machins de cassoulé pour
pour des mois. Ça non, moi je suis pas
dans cette logique là. Je sais que là où
j'habite, si ça merde quand je suis là
où j'habite, évidemment, si ça tourne ce
soir, j'ai pas de chance. Mais si ça
s'il se passait des choses comme ça, euh
je sais que là où je suis, je serais pas
sûrement le le premier à passer par la
fenêtre. Mais bon, c'est dérisoire.
C'est quelques coups d'avance par
rapport à un merdier total qui me
rattrapera peut-être quoi qu'il arrive.
C'est pour ça que je souhaite pas cet
effondrement. Moi, je j'ai jamais connu
ça. Je serais peut-être en boule dans un
coin, j'en sais rien. Je peux pas du
tout imaginer comment je je ferai face.
C'est pour ça que je dis c'est peut-être
mieux de penser maintenant à trouver des
solutions pour éviter ça.
Le gouvernement suédois, d'ailleurs, je
crois bien préconise d'avoir 2 semaines
de stock de nourriture
en cas de catastrophe climatique ou
d'invasion russe.
Il faut avoir du pognon, de l'or et
cetera, enfin deux trois trucs. Oui. Je
sais pas si le gouvernement suédois
préconise d'avoir du pognon. Euh
non, les gouvernements préconisent pas
ça. Mais c'est mieux.
Tu as de l'or chez toi
ça ? Sinon les mecs vont venir toquer à
ma porte avec insistance. Donc
tu vas les accueillir avec du compté ?
Bah bien sûr, on n'est pas des bêtes.
Euh compter 20 jaunes.
Ah oui ouais. Château chalon, déboucher
le temps avant et cetera. Ouais ouais,
il faut faire ça bien.
Et poulet au mor vin jaune,
pourquoi pas ? Ouais, pourquoi pas ? Tu
as une formation médicale genre les
premiers secours autres ?
Ouais enfin c'est j'ai je sais même plus
si j'avais fait un truc de sauveteur
secouriste au travail un machin comme ça
mais je sais je connais les bases.
Est-ce que tu comprends que tes écrits
et d'autres écrits d'ultradooite
peuvent générer des conduites
stressantes de repli sur soi de paranoïa
chez certains ?
Bah je pense qu'elles existent enfin
elle me elle me précèdent. C'est comme
quand on dit ces news fait monter
l'extrême droite, les machins. Je pense
pas. Je pense que au contraire c'est
nous on s'adapte à la situation
actuelle. On essaie d'y apporter des
réponses qui soient à mon avis moins
mauvaises que le que le un autre délire.
Donc oui, enfin je encore une fois
malheureusement on peut tout on peut
tout faire avec un bouquin.
Un type peut lire une phrase très
différemment de la manière dont je l'ai
écrite. Et j'y peux rien.
Si je te dis un homme ça s'empêche,
ça te fait penser à quoi ?
Un homme ça s'empêche
rien.
Albert Camu.
D'accord.
Revenons à notre sujet dans ton bouquin.
Je suis pas bon citation
esprit de l'escalier dans ta dans ton
bouquin, tu parles de
Ouais mais parce que quand tu écris, tu
as l'intelligence
qui cristallise. C'est pas pareil. Tu as
tout qui vient. Quand tu parles, c'est
pas du tout pareil. Tu parles pas du
tout de la même manière.
Tu choisis toujours des figures très
virilistes,
les spiat
du moins
virilist. Ah oui
qui portent leur
Paul Valérie. Physiquement on a fait
mieux. Mais non, mais par exemple, mais
par contre mentalement, on n pas fait
mieux quasiment d'un point de vue de la
virilité intellectuelle.
Capable de remettre à ce point en cause
le le l'univers et tout ce qui a été
pensé avant, pendant toutes les figures
et cetera. Ça c'est c'est un vrai
courage. Il avait sûrement plus de
courage que même des Spartiates.
Question internet.
Tu en connais beaucoup des Sparciat ?
Non mais c'est une déduction étudie quoi
? étudia quoi des sparciates ? Oh
comme tout le monde. 300 c'est ça ?
Non non mais
pourquoi tu parles de Frodon saqué tout
au long de ton bouquin ? Ah parce que je
trouve que la comparaison assez génial.
Ce qui fait d'ailleurs j'ai fait une
légère connerie là-dessus mais c'est pas
grave. Mais le le petit hobbit, je
t'expliquer ça, c'est le petit hobbit
qui est qui est rien qui machin qui veut
protéger sa petite comptée verdoyante
d'une menace
qui pèse une emprise sur les esprits. Le
pouvoir de l'anneau symbolisé par ce
tout-puissant machin qui régit les âmes
avec toutes les forces qu'il a agrégé à
lui, les serumanes, les machins. Donc le
mord d'or par exemple, ce serait un peu
les les sciences sociales et cetera.
Enfin, tout est contre ce ce petit
personnage qui va trouver deux trois
alliés et qui va se dire "Il faut que je
détruise un autre pouvoir." C'est un
truc qui c'est simplement un truc
mental, une une emprise sur les esprits
et si je réussis devant tout le monde à
montrer que moi je le crains pas, je
vais je peux le détruire et je peux donc
faire s'évaporer la bête. Euh ma
connerie c'était de de de le faire
détruire l'anneau lui-même, le jeter
dans le feu du machin de la montagne du
destin. En fait, c'est Golou qui le
reprend. Mais bon, c'est Frodon qui a
fait que Golou avait survécu. Bref,
voilà.
Euh peu importe le le la le truc, c'est
que l'anneau du pouvoir est détruit aux
yeux des hommes et donc rend les
individus libres par l'exemple du
courage de Frodon. et ça et toute la
toute la clique qui va avec. Donc ça va
bien se passer. Quel rapport tu as à la
religion ?
un rapport très difficile euh très très
difficile. Moi je je lis mais j'ai
beaucoup lu la Bible et j'ai beaucoup
étudié enfin réfléchi à ces à ça au
messages christiques. Euh par contre
j'ai une grande distance avec les
croyants de manière générale. Je trouve
souvent que ils le sont mal ou pour de
mauvaises raisons que les prières me
paraissent toujours justement relevé de
l'amondicité.
s'il te plaît, Dieu, fais que je j'ai
mon j'ai mon BP, j'en sais rien. Enfin
voilà, c'est triste et c'est toujours
cette image du de la petite créature qui
veut son maître qui qui qui estime que
tout va passer par le maître et beaucoup
moins par elle-même fait anarchiste
le peut-être un peu mais anarchiste
comme Jésus qui lui dit justement
individu euh c'est à toi, c'est tout
repose sur toi. pas le collectif, c'est
pas parce que tu suis bien les précepts
machin, c'est pas parce que tu pries au
carrefour devant tout le monde ou que tu
vas à la messe le dimanche que tu peux
derrière te comporter comme un connard
et que ça annulera tout. Au contraire,
tu dois prendre sur toi et tu dois
peut-être
mieux faire, moins parler et ça ira
mieux pour toi.
Comment on fait pour trouver un
consensus
entre l'ultra droite, la droite, la
gauche, l'ultra gauche pour essayer
d'affronter tous ensemble
les tomb de merde qui se profilent à
l'horizon.
Parce que si je t'écoute,
je me mets dans la peau de l'ultra
gauche, je vois des gars en train de
s'endurcir le culte du corps, de
l'esprit, de l'alimentation, de
Roberette et j'en passé des meilleurs et
je veux faire péter au TNT leur moral.
Euh je je leur
je je leur Ouais, c'est déjà beaucoup
quand même. Non.
Oui. Oui. Mais
je veux je veux euh me libérer de leur
emprise. Tu comprends que ça peut
générer d'autres démons en face dans
d'utiliser ce champ lixical, cette
approche, comment on fait pour
réconcilier tout ce bon ? Parce que nous
on vous regarde
h
tant à l'ultra droite qu'à l'ultra
gauche en passant par l'ultra centre, en
passant par
l'Islam, les câau, les bouddhistes, les
Russes, les Américains. On fait tous les
spectres de tout le monde. On essaie de
comprendre tout le monde. Alors, on a
quand même cette carte diminé,
c'estàdire qu'on peut discuter à peu
près avec tout le monde.
Hm.
Comment on fait pour réconcilier tout ce
beau monde ? Est-ce qu'il faut pas un
peu de bienveillance, d'entraide, de se
tendre la main, dire "OK, vous m'avez
blessé ? jeté blessé, on essaie de se
réconcilier à la cato.
Ouais, on oui, tout à fait. Bah pour ça,
le problème c'est qu'il faut renoncer à
ces identités de substitution,
ses étiquettes. Bah par exemple, moi je
me dis pas entrant chez moi qu'est-ce
que j'ai été d'ultro Drot aujourd'hui,
je suis très content. Euh ouais, non, je
fais pas ça. Euh et voilà, si on
commence par ne pas faire ça parce
qu'encore une fois, ce sont des
étiquettes qu'on s'amuse à mettre, c'est
pratique mais il faut il faut évidemment
dépasser ces trucs-là. Euh si on cherche
pas à être le tyran des autres, euh
peut-être qu'on a de meilleures chances
de s'entendre. Mais encore une fois,
gauche, c'est le tyran, c'est ton tyran.
L'ultra gauche, disons que elle
voudrait, c'est le le tiran du tyran.
C'est euh dire que le le tiran total
devrait l'être encore beaucoup plus.
C'est ça le message euh de mon si on
enfin je sais pas si on prend Mélenchon,
lui il voudra pas moins d'appareils, il
voudra toujours beaucoup plus
d'appareils, toujours beaucoup plus de
contrôle, d'emprise, de moins de
liberté, de d'expression chez
l'adversaire. Oui, oui, mais encore un
peu plus quand même. Donc enfin, moi je
c'est pour ça que je je vois ça comme le
bloc sectaire et que l'hérésie
consisterait justement à dire non, ce
qu'il faut c'est moins plus de de
d'autonomie pour les créat. Pourquoi
tu dis pas aposta ?
Par rapport à la secte, je Bah parce que
ça soit mieux aposta, la moitié des
lecteurs sont obligés de vérifier ce que
ça veut dire. C'est c'est pénible. Alors
qu'érésie, on voit ce que ça veut ce que
ça évoque. Le bûcher. Le bûchet un peu
plus proche. Voilà, c'est ça.
Jean d'c. Jeun d'Arc ? Oui. Oui. Je d'c
euh si on est si on est des jeunes d'c
mais euh voilà, refuser de
justement ne pas se jeter dans une autre
une autre tyrannie euh de pas vouloir
imposer aux autres faire la même chose à
l'envers. Pour moi, le type qui se dit
de droite et qui veut faire terre les
mecs de gauche, les privés de lieu de
machin ou de je sais pas quoi, il est
dans l'erreur aussi. C'est le même
fascisme, c'est la même chose. Euh et
ça, je veux éviter ça. Moi, je suis pas
de de ce clan-là, mais bon, après voilà,
faut faire l'effort de lire et de
comprendre. Et
donc, tu es tu es euh cfondateur de la
maison d'édition, c'est ça ?
Ouais, les éditions Magnus. Ouais.
C'est quand même vachement connoté ce
que tu édites.
Oui.
Pourquoi ? parce que ils ont bien du mal
à exister ailleurs. Je pense que je sais
pas si aujourd'hui Papacito ou Marceau
vont frapper à la porte de chez Fire. Je
suis pas sûr qu'on les laisse entrer.
Peut-être que aussi.
Euh alors, ce serait une expérience à
tenter, mais on sait jamais hein. C'est
vrai que les choses les choses évoluent,
mais en tout cas pour euh pour l'instant
c'était pas le cas. Et nous, on s'est
dit justement la meilleure manière de
défendre nos intérêts est d'être
indépendant, de pas nous mettre dans une
maison d'édition euh de mieux la
contrôler, de mieux en contrôler la
diffusion, la communication. Donc ça
paraissait normal, c'est ce que je prône
l'indépendance, l'autonomie, ça en fait
partie. Et on est évidemment euh libre
des aides d'État euh avec la Furia
aussi, la revue la Furia euh
indépendante aussi et on essaie
justement d'apporter euh une petite
touche de d'humour en plus. Essayer
aussi de de faire un peu rire, de voilà
de proposer quelque chose, une for une
offre culturelle alternative parce que
c'est ça aussi qui manque.
Malheureusement, la droite critique
énormément l'offre culturelle existante
en disant "C'est de la merde. Les
jeunes, ils écoutent de la merde, ils
pensent mal.
Mais voilà, eux, qu'est-ce qu'est-ce
qu'on propose ? On propose souvent des
trucs très poussé, très chiants, très
très qui n'ont aucune valeur
d'accomplissement aujourd'hui. Donc
c'est aussi l'autocritique qu'on doit
faire.
Question internet.
Bonjour. Votre invité peut-il nous
donner la définition du mot empathie ?
Merci pour votre travail.
Génial. Génial. Mais l'empathie, la
capacité à se mettre à la place. Bah
parce que c'est drôle, je trouve. C'est
à de sa part parce que je suppose qu' il
sous-entend de manière très subtile que
j'en suis dépourvu.
C'est des suputations.
Euh bah oui, c'est une suut enfin je
pense parce que je au contraire je pense
que je me mets
c'est une suutation de ta part.
Je parviens euh Oui, mais justement
l'empathie c'est la capacité à se mettre
à la place des autres et à inférer leur
raisonnement et je il me corrigera si je
me trompe mais je pense que c'était à de
sa part. Et l'empathie c'est évidemment
essentiel et très utile. Et moi je je
m'efforce encore une fois de de lire
tout le monde, de comprendre tout le
monde. Et j'explique que quand je dis la
secte, la lycéenne à cheveux vert dont
je me moque mais je comprends son
raisonnement. Je comprends que dans t
jeune
les cheveux
longs
sa mère pas si long que ça mais un petit
peu mais
mais ils étaient pas vert. J'étais Ouais
mais j'ai jamais été de j'étais jamais
un un rebelle de un rebelle de gauche.
J'ai j'ai pas je suis pas passé par
cette case moi. Beaucoup de mecs de
droite je sais ont été de gauche se sont
repentis. Ça a pas été mon cas. Moi je
pas repentis. Genre quand j'entends
repenti, c'est limite c'est
Non mais parce qu'ils ont compris, on
est jeune, on est idéaliste, ils adent,
ils voulaient être connus par le groupe,
ils ont compris ce qui s'est passé, que
c'était une manière de de passer d'aller
vers l'âge adulte. C'est ça l'engagement
politique la plupart du temps quand on
est jeune. Mais encore une fois, je le
comprends. Je je j'ai été jeune aussi.
J'ai sûrement pensé n'importe comment
euh et je suis pas du tout d'ailleurs
encore mû pensée. Il faut attendre des
années et des années, même à la fin, ce
sera peut-être toujours un peu triste vu
de plus loin. Mais j'essaie de faire le
le cheminement et j'essaie de comprendre
vraiment, je pense que il y a un intérêt
à être une lycéenne à cheveux vert
aujourd'hui dans certains endroits.
C'est payant parce qu'on a la sensation
d'exister, on a l'impression de penser
bien, de faire le bien. On comprend pas
pourquoi il y a des méchants fachaots
partout qui qui veulent qui nous veulent
du mal. Et il faut faire cette démarche
de comprendre l'autre justement pour
essayer de les amener à sortir de ça, de
cette fameuse emprise.
Est-ce que tu penses qu'ils ont le même
raisonnement à ton égard ?
Euh honnêtement, j'en ai pas vu beaucoup
l'avoir ce raisonnement. Il a il y a des
gens des fois qui sont venus me voir en
dédicace en me disant "Bah moi, je
pensais pas du tout comme vous. J'ai
réfléchi, vous m'avez fait, vous m'avez
ça m'a challengé, j'ai j'ai un peu
évolué. Et ça, j'en suis très content
parce que c'est très bien et qui suivent
pas du tout aveuglément ce que je dis.
Ça, j'aime pas du tout ça non plus. Euh
et d'autres qui refusent radicalement de
de d'entrer dans dans ce que je suis, ce
que je fais parce que pour eux c'est le
mal et c'est tout. Et c'est confortable
de faire ça, de dire siamo tout anti
fascisti machin et de gueuler, d'essayer
de gueuler plutôt que de d'écouter.
C'est très confortable de on peut pas
malheureusement ça fait partie de de
notre espèce et ça existera toujours.
Dans ton bouquin, tu idéalises
énormément Boloré et tu idéalises
énormément Javier Miley.
Énormément. Bah je l'ai perçu comme quoi
bah disons que
c'était ton copain quoi.
Ils
Boloré Boloré aer les services publics,
dégager toutes les taxes, dégager le à
foiré à foir c'est marqué non ?
Ouais ouais bah non mais alors j'étais
d'accord sur le principe. Maintenant
j'attends de voir la démonstration
concrète il a le beau discours. Il est à
la tête d'un appareil. Qu'est-ce qu'il
peut en faire réellement ? On va voir,
c'est intéressant comme expérience, mais
il a fallu qu'on atteigne le fond du
fond du fond du trou là-bas pour que ça
puisse exister ce genre d'expérience un
peu radicale.
Tu sais ce qu'il faisaient les argentins
pour stocker leur pouvoir d'achat ?
Non,
ils achetaient des parpins et du
contreplaqué. Bah, du plac au plâtre
parce qu'il y avait tellement
d'inflation. Alors, comme ils avaient
pas de pognon, on pour acheter de l'or,
ils achetaient du CORX, des matériaux de
construction pour encaisser le le
l'inflation.
OK. Ben, j'espère que j'espère qu'on
aura de la marge de non jamais. Je je
prier du mois, il y a encore des gens,
il y a des gens même il y a 10 ans hein,
qui font la queue pour retirer
l'intégralité de leur salaire
à la banque.
Ouais. Bah
des je sais plus quatre décennies de
socialisme, n'importe comment quand même
avant ça. Donc
voilà, ça lit comme disait l'autre,
c'est une belle théorie mais c'est on
est la mauvaise espèce et ça marche pas.
C'est qui l'autre ?
Je crois que c'est Edouard Osborne
Wilson.
Mais je suis pas fort en citation. Je
retiens les les belles phrases mais pas
toujours les auteurs. Mais ça Wilson, le
gars qui était sociologiste,
controversé, enfin j'aime bien citer des
gars assez controversés.
Pourquoi ? ou parce que ce sont des
auteurs intéressants justement les
peut-être dangereux
peut-être peut-être ça peut ça peut
arriver mais encore une fois les gars
dangereux sont intéressants.
quelqu'un qui remet en cause qui qui
fait gueuler tous les universitaires,
il il mérite qu'on qu'on s'intéresse à
ce qu'il a fait compétence
parce que forcément ça dit beaucoup de
choses sur justement bah sur moi
peut-être
mais surtout sur le système
universitaire qui gueule. Euh pourquoi
enfin ça donne envie de de comprendre le
truc ? C'est pour ça que c'est souvent
une mauvaise idée de de faire de la
publicité aux mecs comme ça, mais bon,
ils font leur chemin en général et
parfois ils ont raison longtemps après,
longtemps avant, on va dire plutôt.
Est-ce que tu penses qu'on va à la
guerre civile ?
Ben là c'est en tout cas c'est mal
engagé. Guerre civile, c'est toujours un
terme
les mecs de d'ultra gauche contre les
mecs d'ultra droite armé jusqu'au dent.
les mecs d'ultra gauche qui commenc,
je pense plutôt que ce sera tout un tas
de gens contre tout un tas de gens de
manière beaucoup plus indistincte et
instinctive que ça.
On fait quoi pour prévenir ça ? Ben, on
arrête de de donner du crédit à des gens
comme Bruno Lemire et on a on prend
conscience que ce jeu politique, il a
fait que ça. Il a fait que nous
fabriquer un des immenses tombou de
merde qui sont prêts à nous tomber
dessus aujourd'hui. Il a complètement
détruit un pays qui était qui était pas
pas parfait, ça n'existe pas, mais qui
était dans un bien meilleur état que ça
il y a quelques temps et il a amené aux
portes du chaos. Et c'est ça et ça c'est
la politique et c'était pas la meilleure
équipe machin, c'est tout le système.
C'est si vous mettez demain un type euh
qui a l'air euh qui a l'air très bien,
qui est très probe, tout ça, la tête de
tout ça, il pourra il pourra rien faire.
Euh il y a le Conseil tous les
organismes, l'Union européenne machin,
le tous les c'est
le le pouvoir se se protège très bien de
lui-même malheureusement. C'est pour ça
que c'est une machine et que c'est
difficile de lutter contre une machine.
Question internet. Il a combien de
permis ? Fait-il des dons ? Son argent
il le plan coup où il où il s'en sert
pourinterrogation
de permis.
C'est permis voiture, permis de pilote,
permis poids lourd, permis de port
d'arme.
Non voiture, bah port d'arme, ça
n'existe pas vraiment. Disons qu'on a
j'ai les autorisations.
Est-ce que tu milites pour le port
d'armes ? Je milite pas mais je pense
que c'est pas enfin je je j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi le l'État nous a
confisqué nos armes et du coup par
extension euh les seuls qui sont bien
armés sont ceux qui en ont qui se
foutent des lois.
Est-ce que tu connais le taux d'homicde
par arme à feu aux États-Unis ?
Je suppose qu'il est il est assez élevé.
Stratosphérique.
Ouais.
Les mecs pour un oui pour un non sur la
route il s'engueule. Il y en a un qui
sort de taris h
qui sont les les les criminels qui tuent
par arme à feu aux États-Unis ?
Bah tu voir. Je vois l'espèce de de
rébluchge que tu essayes de me faire.
Tuas voir par toi-même
statistiquement. Bah
peut-être les les les populations les
plus précaires, les
Ah, je dis je vise pas les populations,
je vise vraiment des des des criminels.
Des criminels déjà connus, archi connus.
Litu aux États-Unis, je crois qu'on ne
pourt pas beaucoup dans le massacre
général.
Euh le problème à mon avis avant tout
des États-Unis, oui, c'est cette
hétérogénéité, bien plus que les armes à
feu. Mais voilà, ça c'est les les
Suisses, il me semble, sont assez bien
armées et on n' pas ce genre de de
phénomène. Mais bon, encore une fois,
moi je mise c'est un petit peu il y a
une part d'idéalisme de se dire que bah
les individus faut leur faire confiance,
ils peuvent montrer qu'ils peuvent être
responsables. Malheureusement, peut-être
qu' c'est trop tard. Peut-être que sont
ils sont, comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure, les instincts des régulés et
qu'ils feront n'importe quoi avec.
C'est quoi la morale ?
Alors, je te lis une phrase, pour
Chopener, la morale freine notre égoïsme
et notre méchanceté pour fonder une
société où chacun vise le bien de tous.
Que pensent-il
sur la morale de la morale ? Bah, il y a
il y a il y a plusieurs ordres de
morale. Il y a la morale biologique qui
née euh qui fait qu'on calque notre
comportement sur un certain nombre de de
normes. Attends, la morale biologique
innée. Alors, tu penses que il y a des
gènes de récessif autosomal de la morale
? Bah, bien sûr.
Regarde n'importe quel clan.
Comment ça ? Bien sûr.
Bah, je sais pas. Tu observes,
tu observes un groupe de chimpanzés,
n'importe lequel. Tu demandes au aux
spécialistes qui Non non mais tu
demandes aux spécialistes qui les
étudent
et ben voilà et ben il va te dire euh
que tous les comportements ont une
signification euh que il y a une
hiérarchie qui est hyper précise de
n'importe qui même du du chimpanzé est
déterminé par son milieu socioculturel
par son non par son par son instinct
enfin par son programme et il s'adapte à
la à la donnée aux données de la
situation mais il y a un programme au
départ et il obéit à ça. Enfin,
n'importe quel animal est comme ça.
Et donc la morale, tu es en train de me
parler que c'est dans les gènes du sens
la la morale c'est que tu on a la
capacité
euh
biologique qui est né, c'est c'est unme.
Oui. Oui, c'est vrai. C'est c'est vrai.
on a la capacité biologique
de de de sentir,
je sais pas, par rapport à au ça peut
être aux attentes du groupe
qu'on va commettre une faute, qu'on va
se dégrader, qu'on va Mais non, mais
c'est c'est des trucs assez c'est des
trucs assz assez compliqués à expliquer.
Non, mais moi je suis pas en plus, je
suis pas un
Ça tombe bien, on a le temps.
Génial. Mais
alors, tu as 35 km de RAM. Vas-y, vas-y.
Ce que je veux dire, c'est que euh on
comprend quelles sont les attentes du
groupe. On comprend que le groupe, il
est vital pour nous, que on a
l'impression d'être libre mais on ne
l'ai pas. Ça avoir quoi avec le gêne et
l'iné là ? Mais parce que enfin tout ce
qu'on est c'est c'est le fruit d'un d'un
code, d'un programme. Tu es pas par
hasard, tu enfin je sais pas, tu as une
situation, tu tu descends la rue, tu vas
voir quelque chose, tout ce qui se passe
dans ton cerveau, dans tes hormones,
dans ton machin, enfin c'est c'est c'est
tout est écrit.
Non mais tu penses que tu es quoi à
l'intérieur ? Tu es du papier mâché et
que
Et la morale, c'est ça vient de quoi là
? Et ben la morale justement c'est je
sais pas c'est c'est un
on va te laisser sur la tamise faire ton
avis. Non non attends c'est plus un
concept c'est plus un concept
philosophique qu'on plaque sur une une
réalité c'est par exemple ton chien si
tu lui apprends alors tu vas encore me
faire chier avec les chiens. Non non
attends mettons ton cochon tu lui
apprends que quand tu sonnes la
clochette
c'est très intelligent un cochon.
C'est très intelligent un cochon. Quand
tu sonnes la clochette
c'est la c'est il va bouffer. Voilà tu
D'accord.
OK. Donc
donc ça ça s'appelle le réflexe de
je sais pas. Non, c'est Pavelof. Mais ça
c'était avec des chiens. Mais tu veux
pas que je mette des chiens ?
Mais tu peux faire la même chose avec
tout le monde. Oui oui. Bah voilà. Bah
mettons Robert, tu sonnes la cloche,
ça marche. Mais non mais tu lui dis
Robert il est midi, il descend, c'est
pareil.
Si je te dis compter de 36 mois, tu
sais. Voilà. Voilà. Bah évidemment mais
non mais voilà, on est tous pareil. Bon
non très bien. Euh c'est pas moral de
manger du comptet de 36 mois. Il y a
personne dans ton groupe social qui va
juger péjorativement ce ce cette
passion. ou à part peut-être des écolos
qui vont penser qu'il faut pas tr les
vaches, j'en sais rien. Bon mais en tout
cas voilà c'est ça va pas te dévaluer
dans ton groupe. Au contraire, si tu dis
j'ai dû compter de 36 mois, il est bon
euh tu vas faire plaisir aux gens et tu
auras une meilleure estime de toi-même.
Ta réputation euh voilà on sortira
grandi.
Mais ça se partage pas compter 36 moise.
Non mais voilà, je je te dis moi c'est
mon crise de la morale. Non, mais le que
tu tu sais instinctivement qu'il y a des
choses qui sont bonnes, qu'il y a des
choses qui sont mauvaises, il y a des
choses que tu peux faire.
C'est sûr qu'on va éviter de mettre la
main dans l'oubante où on va le faire
une fois, pas deux.
Oui, mais aussi dans ton comportement
social. Il y a tout ce que permet le
code pénal et tout ce qui
paraît répréhensible va attirer sur toi
un jugement péjoratif qui un peu
nébuleux.
Mais c'est nébuleux. Enfin, c'est Non,
mais c'est parce que c'est tellement
évident que c'est nébuleux. Et parce que
personne m'a jamais demandé d'expliquer
un truc aussi
aussi visible. Je sais pas.
Pas de questions sur internet.
Ouais. Ouais. Non mais je j'en j'en
doute sur internet. Allez
l'animal moral de White, il y a tout un
bouquin là-dessus, il faut lire ça.
Question internet. Est-ce que monsieur
Auberton a déjà pleuré ?
Pleuré ça a dû m'arriver. Oui.
Que pens que pensez-vous du deuxème
amendement de la Constitution des
États-Unis
sur la voilà, il faut me le citer parce
que alors ça je moi je suis pas dans la
dans ce genre de de spécialité. les
armes à feu, la détention des armes,
machin, tout citoyen le droit de Bah
oui. Enfin, moi je trouve que si l'État
n'est pas notre ennemi qui nous fait
confiance, s'il a pas de raison de nous
de nous dépouiller de nos armes. Là, on
est dans le postulat inverse. L'État
patiemment, petit à petit,
seul décepierre
et compagnie disaient pas ça. Disaient
il faut justement que les citoyens
soient armés pour se défendre contre les
tyrans.
Tu es plutôt Robespierre ou tu es plutôt
Mara ?
Aucun des deux. C'était des types enfin
je suis pas des masses révolutionnaires.
Je pense justement que ça a été une
accélération du problème. L'appareil
d'État après la révolution, il avait
justement plus du tout de contrepouvoir
et il était il était hors limite.
Question internet. Pourquoi avoir fait
des enfants s'il pensent que la France
va s'écrouler et qu'il va y avoir une
guerre civile ? Mais justement, ça c'est
c'est ce raisonnement déjà me terrifie
parce que si on pense que la situation
va être difficile, on se suicide tout de
suite, on arrête de jouer. Mais la vie,
le problème de la domestication, c'est
qu'on conçoit la vie comme l'évitement
permanent
de de l'inconvénient, de l'épreuve. Mais
la vie, elle ne elle ne elle n'existe
que par l'épreuve. Si nos ancêtres sont
devenus très forts, c'est parce qu'ils
ont affronté des conditions de de vie
très dure. Et justement, c'est c'est
comme ça qu'on acquier une expérience,
qu'on devient quelqu'un, qu'on peut
s'accomplir. Euh donc je enfin ce refus,
mais ça c'est très caractéristique de
l'époque, le "n faisons rien, c'est plus
prudent, on va pas se reproduire surtout
pas nos pauvres enfants." Mais ceux
d'avant, ils sont pas dit ça en 14
machin, il bouffaiit du rat dans les
tranchées. Ils se sont reproduits. On
est là. Ça veut dire que eux ils ont ils
ont vécu des trucs. Il y avait pas la
SQ, il y avait pas les Sal à l'amé.
C'était c'est on a vécu. Oui. B C'est
gratuit parce que en passant ça fait
plaisir.
Mais ça fait plaisir à ton ego ?
Non, même pas.
C'est un reflet d'immaturité.
Oui, sans doute. Mais je suis un ami un
animal domestique, donc c'est mon côté
juvénil. Je joue
en fait, j'en profite. Pourquoi faire
des petits taquets derrière la tête à
quelques journalistes dans ton bouquin ?
C'est imagé ça.
C'est immature.
C'est imagé.
Ça illustre des situations parce que
j'ai constaté le lecteur, il aime bien
les exemples, il aime pas le
raisonnement froid machin. Donc il faut
dire il faut vous bah je sais pas
peut-être peut-être le mien peut-être
celui des autres, j'en sais rien. Mais
en tout cas j'ai l'impression que les
livres plus imagés euh parlent plus et
que les bons exemples fonctionnent
mieux. Donc c'est une je m'adapte au
c'est une bonne question. Je je moi je
cherche la structure de communication
absolue. J'ai essayé des romans, j'ai
essayé des essais, j'aimerais bien
essayer des fables. J'ai j'ai plusieurs
et le dessin je dessine très
malheureusement et je me dis que c'est
tard pour commencer quand je vois le
temps que ça prend pour être bon.
Est-ce que tu t'es essayé à la poésie ?
Non, enfin comme un comme n'importe quel
adolescent, j'ai dû faire des verrs
exécrables et non, je suis pas allé plus
loin.
Pourquoi ?
Je sais pas. J'aime beaucoup en plus la
poésie
les autres.
Mais ouais lesquel
? Enfin je sais pas euh Baudler
évidemment Saint-Jeun Perse euh pour un
plus récent mais sinon
tu es capable de m'en réciter un
de Saint-Jeun Perse ? Non
ça ser ça ne peut pas se réciter
quelle est la poésie que tu connais par
cœur et qui te fait vibrer ?
Moi ce serait plus des fables pour le
coup. Pour moi, c'est les fables de la
fontaine. Enfin, les œuvres qui ont le
plus de résonance en moi à tous les
égards, c'est les fables de la fontaine.
Je sais pas
euh
ils sont tous enfin c'est c'est c'est
tout est parfait chez lui. C'est
je sais pas. Ne faut-il que délibérer la
cour en conseiller foisonne-il besoin
d'exécuter ? On ne rencontre plus
personne. Enfin, tout est parfait. C'est
question internet. Monsieur Aberton
croit-il au réchauffement climatique ?
Je crois que le climat n'est pas un truc
qu'on peut réguler qui est stable tout
le temps.
Oui ou non ?
Et bah non mais enfin je sais pas
peut-être que a priori il paraît que ça
se réchauffe. Je suis pas expert. Bah je
suis
des experts des comités des machins
disent ça se réchauffe. Apparemment il
est très très urgent de penser que ça se
réchauffe. Donc peut-être qu'ils ont
raison. Pour le coup je je suis je passe
mon tour sur le sujet. Je suis pas
spécialiste, mais moi ce qui
m'intéresse, c'est l'utilisation qu'on
en fait. C'est-à-dire, admettons que euh
ces gens aient raison, que la situation
soit alarmante et cetera. Le problème,
c'est que leur seule solution consiste à
donner des postes et des moyens à des
gens comme Laurent Fabius euh pour voter
des lois, des interdits, des taxes, des
machins euh et entretenir un business
sur des énergies renouvelables qui qui
servent à rien.
Et voilà, c'est c'est ce que je
constate, c'est le le l'usage qui est
qui en est fait. Mais bon, après
peut-être que ça monte, peut-être ça
descend, je sais rien. Je sais pas si le
fait que Robert s'arrête de rouler avec
son diesel change quelque chose.
Se chauffer au foule.
Ouais, bon, je ne sais pas.
Ou manger du comté.
Bah oui, ça contribue he
malheureusement. On est tous
Quelle lecture tu as de des gilets
jaunes et quelle lecture tu as de la
crise avec les agriculteurs ? les gilets
jaunes, c'était intéressant parce que
c'est vraiment le le peut-être un des
seuls mouvements de ces dernières années
qui n'était pas euh une réponse
justement le le l'État qui jette ses
récompenses partout et le fameux euh les
les comment dire les mouvements sociaux,
la spécialité de la France. Donc des
types qui vont péter des trucs, qui vont
bloquer des trucs en disant on veut on
veut plus parce que machin bon très
bien, ils gueulent très fort, on va leur
donner et à vous et cetera. Et là à
l'inverse, c'était dire non mais là en
fait on est en train de crever, on peut
plus rouler, on peut plus bosser parce
que l'état il est beaucoup trop présent.
Au départ c'était vraiment ça. Et ça
évidemment l'appareil il a pas du tout
aimé. Là c'était pas possible. On
pouvait plus du tout péter des vitrines.
C'était plus bon enfant, c'était plus
gauloir et frractaire, ça ne marchait
plus. Donc euh l'État a fortement réagi
et heureusement pour lui, les
associations de gauche et machin ont
complètement digéré le truc en en en
faisant un mouvement normal de
revendication qui appelait à plus
d'état, plus d'argent, plus d'aide et
donc tout était rectifié. C'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé avec les
agriculteurs. J'ai peur que ça fasse la
même chose. On va comme d'habitude faire
des promesses, sortir des chèqus et et
comme d'habitude.
Est-ce que tu comprends qu'il y a des
gens d'ultra droite qui veulent pas
venir se faire interviewer ici parce que
sur ce même siège, il y a eu des gens
d'ultra gauche qui sont venus ?
Non, je comprends pas ça. Je bah je
comprends pas ça. Enfin, c'est après
c'est leur logique, ils ont le droit
d'être dogmatique comme ça. Moi ça me
paraît ça me paraît je sais pas, c'est
pas une bonne raison. Je comprends qu'on
puisse ne pas vouloir parler. Moi,
j'aime pas, enfin j'aime pas
spécialement parler. Je suis pas à
l'aise avec ça. Je préfère écrire mais
je me dis que c'est une c'est un moyen
aussi de faire connaître ce que ce que
j'écris. Mais après qu'on refuse de
venir parce que l'autre enfin l'autre
croquant machin, ça je comprends pas.
C'est pas du tout ma logique.
Alors la deuxème deuxème partie de la
question sur l'échauffement climatique,
si la réponse est oui, que compte-t-il
faire avec les millions de déplacés
climatiques qui vont débarquer d'ici
2050 comme le prédit comme prédit par le
JC entre parenthèses qui a déjà fait
quoi quoi ce qui a déjà fait eu raison
pour le passé. Bon ok laisse tomber. Ne
pense-t-il pas qu'il vaut mieux se
préparer à les intégrer plutôt que de
dépenser de l'énergie pour les repousser
? Mais enfin les intégrer vu les vu les
chiffres qui sont annoncés par ces
organismes, ce sera nous on sera une
petite goutte dans l'intégration de ce
mouvement de masse.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On fait des murs,
on met des miles en chien par tous les
moyens. Ouais, il faut essayer de de de
défendre ce qu'on est. Moi enfin oui
c'est c'est bassement identitaire le
convient.
Bah on est un peuple, on est une
culture, une civilisation, je sais pas
comment on peut le prendre, à quel
niveau de largeur de de Mais enfin moi
ça me paraît ça me paraît important. Je
pense qu'on est pas seulement le produit
d'une de l'éducation nationale ou d'un
moment, c'est plus profond que ça et ça
fait partie aussi du vivant. Chacun doit
a le droit de de de d'exister.
Et malheureusement, l'Occident par son
universalisme a largement contribué à
ses
aux exodes qui viennent, qui sont déjà
en cours parce qu'il a voulu imposer son
modèle qui était encore une fois pour le
bien de tous, le fameux. surtout il a un
peu pillé toutes les colonies et c'est
poch ça c'est c'est discutable parce que
je pense plutôt que encore une fois des
types idéalistes à la ferie et compagnie
se sont dit on va aller civiliser ces
braves sauvages on va leur apporter nos
lumières et on fait ça vraiment dans le
pour le bien pour leur bien ils ont
c'est ce qui c'est ce qu'il croyaient
c'est ce qu'on fait toujours. Il y a
toujours des humanitaires, des gens qui
veulent développer à tout prix ces pays
en pensant que le développement
économique, le libre marché, le machin,
c'est ce qui c'est c'est tout ce qui
leur manque. Mais peut-être que
peut-être qu'on se trompe, peut-être que
c'est pas ce qu'il fallait faire mais
bon voilà.
Faire quoi ?
Bah je rien faire. Il fallait quand
juste aller choper le
quand agir n'est pas nécessaire. Non
non, ça c'était pas nécessaire non plus.
Moi je je suis contre le vol et je pense
pas qu'il fallait faire ça mais j'étais
pas aux affaires à l'époque. Quel quel
regard tu portes sur l'esclavage ?
Ah l'esclavage bah c'est
triangulaire.
Ouais, c'est un truc qui existe
toujours, qui était un peu la norme de
l'humanité encore une fois humanité
domestique égale des gens possédés par
d'autres. Mais
et puis on a évolué puis on a compris
que les gens étaient égaux, que
on signe des contrats maintenant mais
bon c'est
euh il y a des formes d'esclavage plus
pernicieuses que ça. Euh encore une
fois, nous on travaille tous pour des
gens pour lesquels on n pas envie de
travailler. On le fait quand même et on
est tenu de le faire. Bon, il faut je
sais pas, il faut pas perdre de vue ces
ces notions là. Mais évidemment, moi
j'ai enfin oui non j'ai tendance à être
contre le fait de posséder autrui.
Alors question que je découvre avec
vous. A-t-il déjà réussi à vaincre
quelqu'un de la entre guillemets secte
à le vaincre, à le à le convertir ? Bah
je
Pourquoi tu utilises ce champ lexical ?
J'ai été éton j'ai été étonné par
Parce que toi aussi tu as ta tu as ta
paroisse ton église c'est ça ? C'est
c'est des curels d'église de culte. Non
non, justement je pense à le je pensais
plutôt à le convertir à l'esprit
critique. Mais
quel argument on fait mouche ? Je je
sais pas parce que il y a beaucoup de de
ces individus qui sont censés
représenter la secte euh qui
publiquement en sont le les
portees-paroles et qui en privé euh ont
d'énormes doutes, voire ont déjà changé
complètement d'opinion, mais ils ont
simplement l'opinion que qu'il est
convenu d'avoir dans leur dans leur
milieu social. Quand on veut survivre,
quand on est en haut, on est obligé de
se conformer encore plus. C'est pour ça
que le sectarisme dans les dans les
sciences sociales, dans les universités,
dans les médias est épouvantable. le
déviant, il va il a une il va prendre
cher, il va se faire dégager. Donc on
est obligé d'être très conforme mais il
y a beaucoup de ces individus-là, même
dans ces milieux-là qui ont déjà changé
d'idée. Je pense que mes opinions
sont pas loin d'être majoritaires dans
ce pays. Elles le sont peut-être déjà,
mais
il manque le mouvement du banc des
sardines quoi, le le courage. On a
encore peur des activistes qui sont
actifs et du coup le mouvement n'arrive
pas.
Il y a une inertie, c'est comme le
Titanic.
Autre question,
sous quelle sous quelle condition la
entre guillemets secte pourrait accepter
d'entendre son discours ?
Je ça c'est à elle qu'il faudrait le
demander. Euh je pense que la le
problème encore une fois de la SECE,
c'est qu'elle elle pourrait s'adapter
intelligemment à l'opinion en lui
donnant quelques gages, quelques
retaillot, quelques individus comme ça,
quelques sarcosies, même par des mesures
assez simples pourraient sauver sa
situation, en tout cas retarder sa sa
chute. Mais le le problème de d'une
machine sans pilote, c'est que il y a
l'activisme, il y a cette pression
permanente et bah aujourd'hui, je sais
pas, tous ces gens ont tous peur de leur
ombre et ont peur de de d'évoluer parce
que ils ont peur d'être accusés, d'être
que ça tombe sur eux. Ils ont tous des
choses à perdre. On a tous des choses à
perdre et personne n'ose voilà n'ose
avancer.
Question internet. Qui serait le Laurent
Aberton de gauche selon lui ? et
serait-il prêt à débattre avec lui pour
créer un pont avec l'autre audience ?
Je sais pas si ça existe. Moi,
j'aimerais bien parler avec des gens, je
sais pas, des la gazneries, des j'ai
parlé avec Mathieu Lama une fois, je
parlerai peut-être avec Thomas Guolé un
jour, j'espère.
J'ai enfin j'ai pas peur de ça, mais
après je constate que de certains ne
sont pas ne partagent pas cette cet
avis.
Est-ce que tu as un sujet que tu
souhaiterais aborder avec nous qu'on n
pas abordé ?
Écoute, on a
je vais avoir c'est ça m'agace parce que
je sais que quand je vais descendre cet
escalier, j'aurai des idées où le
remonter. D'ailleurs, on sait pas,
laissons un peu de suspense. Et je sais
que j'aurais
Ouais. Ouais.
Je sais que je vais avoir tout un tas de
sujets qui vont arriver et je vais
regretter de pas de de pas le faire mais
c'est encore c'est l'esprit de
l'escalier. Je suis condamné, c'est
terrible.
J'ai pas le voilà ce je souffre de cette
j'ai j'ai pas ce sens de la répartie qui
ferait de moi un excellent théâtre des
enfin un excellent acteur du du cirque
télévision.
Est-ce que tu sais affuter une hache ?
Ouais mais oui oui. Bah à force on est
un peu obligé. Je fute avec quoi ?
Bah comme tout le monde, je pense c'est
très primaire.
Petite meule, un petit bout de machin et
la petite meule.
Oh la petite meule, bah je travaille à
l'ancienne moi.
La meule chaude électrique, pied, papier
quelque
ah bah on tourne à la manivelle et ouais
j'ai du vieux matériel mais ça marche
très bien. Mais la hache est un
instrument génial dans son équilibre, sa
façon de décupler notre force. C'est
très rare.
Tiens, un mec d'extrême droite qui pose
une question avec un pseudo un peu
crétin.
Pourquoi l'interview devient un
interrogatoire ? Est-ce que tu as
l'impression que je te fais un
interrogatoire ?
Non, mais mais alors mais ça je enfin ça
m'a frappé la dernière fois que j'étais
passé ici, c'est que le public s'était
scindé en deux. d'un côté euh je sais
pas l'extrême droite ou les qui qui
pensait que tu étais odieux et que sans
respect machin et que c'était j'étais
traité comme un comme une
Pissé quand même.
Oui, tu es parti pisser. C'est c'est
vrai.
Et de l'autre côté justement
dire que ta réponse qui a déclenché mon
pipi, je t'ai trouvé profondément
irrespectueux face aux gens de SOS
Méditerranéen.
Ah c'est possible. Et envie de pisser.
Je me souviens plus du
Non, tu avais dit que les mecs qui
faisaient On retrouvera mais de tête euh
euh tu avais dit que les mecs qui
faisaient de l'humanitaire, c'est
simplement des gens qui cherchent à
avoir la fame
Ah bah non mais attends, tu te trompes ?
Mais non, ils se font du bien à
eux-mêmes, c'est tout. Non mais c'est
eux qui se trompent et du coup,
accordons-nous sur ce désaccord.
Euh c'est voilà il enfin quand quand on
fait un acte perçu comme bon, c'est
évident qu'on le fait.
pour notre estime de nous-même
parce que tu as peut-être envie de
soulager la peine des autres.
Oui, mais c'est là qu'on est vicieux
avec nous-même. Notre cerveau il nous
Mais si c'est encore une fois, c'est
beaucoup plus facile de penser qu'on
agit pour le bien sans avoir les
conséquences, la réflexion un peu froide
et un peu détaé.
Non mais c'est pas ça. Mais il faut
avoir cette réflexion.
Et pour en finir avec le le truc, donc
d'une part, tu as l'extrême droite qui
pensait que tu étais un odieux salot
machin et de l'autre côté l'extrême
gauche qui
doute pas une seconde
l'extrême gauche qui pensait au
contraire que tu étais d'une
complaisance affreuse à mon égard et que
déjà je devrais pas être être là parce
que ça ça ouvre la fenêtre la fenêtre
d'Overton d'Overton facile et que voilà
tu tu devrais pas faire ça. Bon c'est
dommage.
Et ben on est en France et on fait ce
qu'on veut.
Alors, il pensent quoi de l'avortement ?
Tu penses quoi de l'avortement ? On déjà
posé quand même question ça.
Oui, tu me l'as posé tout à l'heure.
Bah, je je te dis que tu av Paul Watson.
Paul Watson, le prix Nobel s'amuse non
pas encore.
J'espère
celui qui s'amuse à faire des autos
tamponneuses avec les balinés japonais
en pleine mer.
OK.
Et qui leur balance des bou puant du et
du beurre pourri. Écoute, chacun ses
petites passions. Moi, je je j'avoue, je
connais enfin je connais très peu. J'ai
entendu parler vaguement mais je voilà,
je sais pas. Euh
là, il toule là quand même là. D'accord.
Bah c'est que
tu connais pas le dossier ?
Non, je je connais pas le honnêtement la
géopolitique en général
il a demandé aussi l'asile en France.
Ah ah bah elle sera pas accordée en
France. Bah parce qu'il a demandé à la
France. La France n'accorde pas l'asile.
Enfin, il y en a qui ont essayé, ils ont
eu des problèmes. Non, mais
de Juniange,
oui, par exemple. Oui.
Euh, mais non, mais enfin, tout ce qui
est géopolitique, je m'y intéresse pas
des masses. C'est un peu comme la
psychanalyse traiter traiter les qu'une
des choses dans tes bouquins, c'estàdire
la petite condition française.
Ben non, mais sans doute mais moi je
enfin, j'assume ce côté
psychologie naïve. Je ma mes
préoccupations terre à terre, c'est
j'admets ça. Je je Ouais, je je
m'intéresse plus à ça qu'à des qu'à des
justement la géopolitique où n'importe
qui peut dire n'importe quoi plus ou
moins impunément. Euh
bah
ouais, puis c'est plus c'est parce que
on peut pas on peut beaucoup moins
vérifier, les médias se font plaisir
donc c'est enfin il faudrait du temps,
il faudrait beaucoup de travail pour
faire ça. Faudrait s'y consacrer. Moi je
fais pas ça. Je
énormément en France. Je sais pas si tu
as remarqué, énormément d'experts en
géopolitique.
Ah mais oui,
tu as l'impression
qui sont connectés avec les services de
renseignement au plus haut niveau 24h
sur 24 sous le robinet. Et ensuite mais
ça c'est enfin moi je vais sur un
plateau machin, on va me dire qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez vous machin et je
vais donner mon avis et comme si je
j'avais un avis à donner. Enfin oui,
c'est comme ça. C'est comme ça que ça
marche. C'est pour ça il faut savoir
faire un sujet qu'on a pas abordé
euh beaucoup de sujets qu'on a pas
abordé mais
cétait toujours pas revenu.
Écoute non.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Intéressant. Alors là,
allez, faut un cour de Lawrence,
n'importe lequel, ils se font plaisir.
L'om en péril. Allez, hop, il est bien
celui-là. Euh, ça c'est important.
guerre de Laurent Burton. Je me je me
cite en deuxè mince, pardon.
Euh et ben les fables de la fontaine.
Allez, allons-y. Et puis euh je sais
pas, Paul Valérie.
Ouais, tel quel, c'est chiant mais
mauvaise pensée. Allez.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ?
Les jeunes générations, bah de Ouais. de
continuer à lire des bouquins, de
d'essayer de de surtout échapper à ces
au dogmes, au à la pensée qui n'en est
pas une, au refus comme ça, au à
l'enfermement dans un dans un dans un
délire. Euh voilà, j'essaie aussi
d'expliquer dans mon bouquin ces
conseils de de transmission justement
au-delà du simple dressage, donner des
clés. Euh, il faut préparer les enfants,
ils sont là machin. Oui, c'est c'est pas
toujours rigolo la vie mais bah il faut
il y a moyen de se préparer à ça plutôt
que de dire tout va bien se passer et
tout le monde est formidable.
Un autre conseil pour les jeunes
génération
encore une fois
se redresser, lire,
penser l'être humain dans sa biologie.
On n'est pas on n'échappe pas au règne
animal. Euh je vais pas parler des
chiens. parce que tu vas encore gueuler
mais euh on on est un produit
biologique. Mais non mais quand même me
fait une idée, je suis observateur quand
même. Et euh
Michou qui regarde son péquinois hein.
Ah ben mais si madame Michou le
regardait attentivement, elle
apprendrait énormément de choses. Cor
Laoren, c'est exactement ce qu'il a
fait. Pass son temps à regarder madame
Mich pour comprendre le chien.
Oh madame Michu plutôt. Ouais ouais. Non
mais enfin nos contemporains sont des
mines d'information à ciel ouvert. Il
faut s'intéresser à ça, à comprendre
comment ils fonctionnent. Et encore une
fois avant de détester tel ou tel, il
faut comprendre, il y a des mécanismes,
ça s'explique
et les maladies idéologiques sont pas
définitives normalement.
Toujours s'intéresser au chien pour
comprendre le maître.
Je sais pas. Après celui qui vient
d'avoir un qui vient de recevoir un
clébar et tout ça, enfin ça dit pas
grand-chose non plus. Faut être prudent
mais
je sais pas moi enfin en tout cas j'aime
bien m'intéresser déjà au propriétaire
pour pour les pour les pour le reste. On
verra.
Laurent Auertoun Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
[Musique]